all right let's see if this
works are we live it says we're live I
want to make sure tell us that we're
live maybe maybe I assume we can trust
it I think we're live let's act as if we
are if we're live I see waving from me
seconds ago that we are live if we are
live oh we got confirmation Chris Jordan
Marcus Gana H six for us being live
Brian Aid Dan Quinton oh sweet excellent
hello citizens of the reject
Nation we have not done a live stream in
a very very long time a quarter but it
has been a week of comic book goodness
it has and drama at the same time yep so
it started off with a Variety article
followed by a phenomenal Loki episode
with a great um no followed first by a
phenomenal gen V finale and then a Loki
episode which was great and invincible
and then invincible and then a
completely surprising great Echo trailer
at the same time so it's just been kind
of a crazy ass week hold on the chat's
not updating properly there we go oh my
God it's moving so fast now that I hit
the button it's finally there okay there
there's seven people in yeah um anyway
uh before we get started uh thank you so
much guys for being here uh you guys
control The Narrative of this stream and
we do we we're trying to do live streams
to it a Time unless it's like a movie
time that's why Juan's not here so
probably next time it'll be John and Koy
um but at in this moment in time I want
to say thank you for being here also
also wait a minute something's wrong
with the chat thank you Dart Carr for
the Super Chat yeah every to send super
chats or streamlabs it's a phenomenal
way to support the channel especially
during a live stream because playbacks
on these are so finicky and we do not
end a stream until we go through every
single one of them ideally we'd like to
keep this at two hours but we usually
usually clocking at three yep believe
that's our luck here hold on I need to
fix this uh I need to fix this this is
not this is not this there beginning of
the stream is always just little tweaks
TW been three months little tweaks here
and there little tweaks here and there
cuz we want you guys guys's comments to
shine on screen here anyway um yeah
don't worry I know the tack on TI finale
episode's out I'm going to cover that on
our patreon because covered anime on the
main channel is kind of scary MCU is
why is that hidden show that show
it it's so obviously true all righty
well before we go into anything here
because there's a lot of things I want
to talk about I we do want to go over
that Variety article that has been
making the rounds seen a lot of people
being oh my God what did that just
happen Christopher whh tip of
Fire $500 holy that has never
happened in the history of reject nation
that is insanity that's going to pay for
Ko's time to be here for the next couple
hours
right oh my God I'm only 250 an hour so
you got me for two God that means a lot
you know like there's there's a lot of
people who have been out of work lately
who come on the channel so I try to keep
people employed here it truly does it's
a big big part of what we do here is
like there's a whole conversation that
is nuts I'd say half of the reject
Nation on camera staff has been stuck on
strike mhm yeah say a good a good amount
and that turned into quite a
conversation a few months ago so a big
part of has been like make sure I'm
bringing people on that's where you see
a lot lot of them now way more on camera
now please let us do something uh so
yeah it's but it's been great I think
and one thing I do want to thank you
guys do for as well before we really go
into anything is thank you for welcoming
it started off with like you know a few
years ago it was like mainly just me and
then it was John and I and then it was
John Coy and Greg and now there's like
10 of us and I want to appreciate you
guys I really appreciate you guys for
sincerely welcoming everyone onto the
channel it's really awesome to see it I
love the expansion of how we're a big
group and Chris W thank you so much
thank youone so kind attributed so far
anyway uh let's talk we got some things
we got to talk about yeah um we're gonna
go through we will go through the super
chats don't worry you got it you got
that promise we will go through the
super chats and we we want to engage all
you guys in the comments and everything
so this Variety article Koy yeah I want
to get this out of the way right now
I've seeing some people who have already
been like it's fake it's fake it's fake
and now what did they go over in this
Variety article a lot of news we've had
for months what are some of the
specifics uh the blade has been in
troubled production since it began with
some details and some rumors uh they
went through the Marvels having uh
apparently a screening in Texas that was
middling um the only two things out of
those two that are somewhat new is the
rumor of $100 million which wasn't
confirmed and uh an unnamed Source
saying something which could have been
literally like a YouTuber an unnamed
source and then um um the Texas
screening was specified as Texas I think
I'd only heard those was a screening but
now we know the state uh and then there
was um stuff about basically Kevin feige
being stretched thin which spoiler alert
we've known for a few years um there was
stuff about uh what else is in that
article um oh the
blade someone just brought it up in the
chat about about how blade it was one of
the drafts was apparently yeah four wom
he was the fourth lead in his own script
but also I think that the phrasing on
that particular part was like a source
familiar with the scripts that could
literally be like nerd rodic yeah like
that could just be some it could
be I the the funny part about that
article that I really and this is one of
the comments I saw go around and I
couldn't agree more with it was none of
it sounded new to me nothing was new and
I did I I do capes and cows with
Christian over on his channel and the
entire comments section on that video is
like why is Coy think none of this is
new news like it's there's nothing in it
it's new there's like there's like
details that augment but I I'm just so
exhausted by like the stupidity of the
internet man well it's honestly a lot of
it is not new for us sure sure sure
because we've heard it for like a year
everything that we heard like oh they
might get King out because Quantom Mania
is underperforming and Jonathan major
legal problem people don't need to keep
up like we do but they also need to
understand that we do already know it
like I'm not saying they're dumb for not
knowing and I'm saying they're dumb for
not understanding why it's not new very
very annoying thing when people are like
just cuz you know this I'm like yeah but
I'm just quantifying that they're trying
to phrase it as negatively as possible
setting up the Marvels it's phrased
aggressively it's putting out only bad
things and have you seen that tweet
that's going around that's like the MCU
is dead the MCU is alive the MCU is dead
like every other property like that's
what this is It's just marvel is putting
out more content not all of it's working
they're less consistent but they're by
no means dead 800 million dollar
Guardians of the Galaxy was the last
movie in theaters it's just such an
ignorant concept to look at like the
last 2 4 hours and be like everything's
on fire well to kind of see the
perspective of why a lot of people have
been uh why a lot of people have been
I'm getting back to being use because
I'm reading your comments at the same
time while listening to koi while
managing the stream and it's been a
while since we've done this and I
appreciate though I'd rather do it why
would you call ner rotic an
because I've know heard horrible things
about him I don't know dude but but have
you actually seen the channel he's a
brilliant guy I don't know Magnus was on
this channel I don't know who nerd rock
is yeah I just like YouTube's not a
place I enjoy but the the part about it
is is I kind of liken it to what South
Park did with the pandra verse have you
seen that the Pand verse now the panda
verse special what I thought was
interesting about it other than it being
hilarious is that a lot of that I'm like
yeah we've all heard this before but
because it's a little bit more on the
mainstream side because it's South Park
suddenly it's making the round it's
getting a bunch of attention and I would
say the same thing about variety it's
because it's a more certified
publication you know like they're
reputable and that was Christian's take
was that like now it's a credible thing
but there were noed sources so so it's
like yeah someone with a big platform
just said I keep hearing that doesn't
change that I keep hearing so I I
personally uh Winston you know Winston
Marshall he said I think the best
assessment of it I've heard so far is
it's like a uh like the Taylor's version
of an album it's like all the same
information but Taylor's version It's
like a culmination of all the stuff
we've heard before but re-released so
it's like a remix it's still the same
information and also it barely touches
on any of the positive stuff it
definitely feels consciously negative
and to me it's just when someone's not
like when a when the Patriots lost a
game everyone celebrated way more when
they were a dynasty thriving when they
lose a game now no one talks about it
like when Tom Brady was with bich it was
a huge huge thing when they lost now
they're not what they were people just
enjoy celebrating popular things not
doing as well but they keep missing like
Ekko and Loki were within 24 hours of
each other Guardians was the last movie
in theaters it's really just obnoxious
that this is even news it's because of
the strike it's because Marvel is
popular it's because the Marvel Brand is
not as strong as it was but I think it
can come back and it's this tribalism of
something is doing well it's not
something I enjoy as much I'm a hate on
it and hate is way more popular in the
internet because it's vulnerable to like
something it's very easy to say you hate
something because it's safe you can say
like blank and then a lot lot of
people jump on that blank blank with you
whereas if you like are vulnerable
enough to say I enjoy this thing you can
get attacked because like oh you stupid
you like blah blah blah so negativity is
just going to spiral up so variety got
their damn clicks that they wanted it's
a strike they finally had something to
talk about but it wasn't anything new
and every time I talk about this thing
everyone's mad at me for saying it's not
new yeah well I think I think the thing
is is that well while while it might not
be exactly new the part about it
is I I am likely to kind of lean towards
the side is that a lot of this has been
rumors we've heard forever for example
you know like with Secret Wars and and
swapping out Kang with Dr Doom a lot of
these rumors or quotee unquote leaks
whatever you want to call it because
variety is talking about it it's more
likely to be true now you know what I
mean it's also like it's like okay like
how often is variety wrong about I don't
really know I I actually don't know I I
don't I used to be a reputable trade now
they're clickbait but it it I haven't
followed them in a while because they
fell into the internet um but that said
it's like saying like spoiler alert
Romeo and Juliet die like secret ORS you
don't have to know the comics but even
just a Wiki will say like he's on the
cover the comic like Doom spoiler alert
is part of Secret Wars so it's like Kang
Dynasty spoilers will feature Kang like
it's just so obvious I wanted to uh
address this because Coy and I have
talked briefly about this when the
camera is not rolling uh because someone
has normally had if it's I'm going to
address normally I'm not going to like
go out my way to like talk about
something that is a negative thing in
the chat but someone did say essentially
okay COI can't be moved on this he
secretly keeps attacking the article and
reporter because they're saying
something bad about his favorite thing
but it wasn't a hit piece the the thing
the the thing I will state is that and
is not only a defense for Coy it's also
kind of a statement for myself is that
we are actually not defending the MCU
because a lot of it we heard were like
well no I we agree with like everything
that's to be fixed thiss to be fixed the
only thing about it was it's making the
waves as if it's a bombshell right and
and that's that's the part of it might
sound pedantic might sound nitpicky it's
more that guys this is not really a
brand new piece of information here we
agree with all of it yeah we know it's
in disarray we were not fans of quantum
Mania what they're doing with Kang has
not been exactly the clearest Loki
season 2 while a phenomenal season and
one of the best things out of Marvel as
of late arguably the best thing of
Marvel as of late it it has dipped in
viewership and I was thinking about it
when I was on my hike today of why why I
just have to insert there that I worked
out uh why I haven't yet so Greg wants
to rub it in it was it was like why why
is Loki dipping is it is it MCU fatigue
or or what might it be because because
it was so it was so huge season 1 the
numbers on everyone's YouTube channels
were bigger uh ours included and the
viewership reportedly is not as big as
season one and you know when you watch
season 2 you don't need to watch the
rest of the MCU that h of everything
that happened in between the follow
season 2 but I think that's where the
problem has come in is because maybe
there's a lot of people who thought I
haven't been keeping up with Marvel yeah
so I don't I I don't I can't watch
season 2 right now right cuz people feel
behind I know people feel behind like
comics when you like how do I get to
issue 700 yeah but you don't need to
watch any of the MCU stuff in order to
watch season 2 but I think a lot of
people have been programmed with the MCU
to think that way to view things that
way sure you know and I and I wonder how
much of that has actually factored into
why people this season one is beloved
right people love season one it's a
phenomenal season but it's also been
long enough that people don't love it
because it's popular to love it it's
also something whenever I say low is my
favorite MCU show there's a hord of
people that go like oh I was just
talking I'm like I'm sorry your
attention spans that of a but a lot of
people that have like read course I'm
deal with Twitter a lot you can hear in
his 10 voice dude I
just much that said uh I think that
anything that's loved gets hate within
like six months whereas it used to be a
couple years um so like I I just don't
think it's worth the experience of
talking to the public about Marvel
because you're going to have two schools
you're going to have people that
aggressively love it and won't see that
it's flawed or people that aggressively
hate it that won't see that it's not as
dead as people want to say it is well
you see like someone in the chat is
saying like no that's not it the content
is low quality nothing to do with the
connection or any of that I would I I
could see people going I'm not
interested in the MCU anymore because
the quality has been lower but to
immediately presume but to apply that
with Loki season 2 that's I'm saying
isolate the situation lok the story of
Loki surprisingly feels separate even
though it seems very essential to the
Multiverse Saga it's surprisingly feels
like its own thing even from season one
to season two sure like I said you don't
need to watch the other ones in between
so to immediately go the quality the MCU
has been low I'm not going to watch
season two is it the preconceived notion
of con connectivity or is there a
presumption that it's going to be a a
less uh not a good quality episode of
Marvel television because of how they've
received Marvel lately you know what I
mean um or do people just lose interest
because we're we're sort of programmed
to get Seasons sooner than later it has
been a couple years I also think that is
you know when if someone doesn't like
one of the properties they might be out
and that's happening you know more often
than you know if they made five
properties and one was bad that's a
fifth of the time if they make 10
properties and two are bad it's still a
fifth of the time but people might be
more likely to be out because of the
abundance now right right right well
that's our take on the article um we're
going to go back to the chat in just a
tiny bit because you know there's other
things we definitely want to talk about
yeah yeah yeah talk about Loki theories
you know and like while I we know marvel
will thousand keep seeing people uh guys
the reason I randomly picked a YouTuber
that just it's it's a random YouTuber
that spouts hate so nerdrotic is just
someone who I've seen thumbnails of this
is a person that like likes to advertise
negativity I'm someone that doesn't
think negativity has a place in pop
culture because the world is actually on
fire with real ramifications so if you
want to spend your time profiting off of
Art and making it about a negative you
have a no respect for me like the world
out there Beyond art is bad enough I
don't think there's any place in in
picking on actual individuals in being
you know misogynistic sh istic and
racist I'm not saying this person is I'm
saying that that type of YouTuber is and
I have no interest in people that really
look for negativity instead of
positivity and hone in on it I hate this
Variety article because it hones in on
negativity that is somewhat there but
they make it bigger and that's variety
was better than that so this particular
YouTuber or anyone like that keep
complaining that I don't like them
they're of an ilk and I just have no
respect for that type of person they're
vultures they're cancer well I think the
problem of why um I don't know if it's
right prom cuz I I I think the reason
why is because initially how it came
across to to understand where it was
coming from sure sure sure and and I did
just pick a person I didn't know them
well I've seen their thumbnails I
apologize for yeah cuz I talking about
the actual like video contest I
personally can't attest to it uh because
I don't know um I don't know their work
I don't know I I personally don't know
neurotics uh videos there's someone that
like 15 times was like if you like this
you may like this so I just saw enough
of them that I was like I don't want
that so apologies if you're an angel
yeah um well anyway guys let's uh let's
swing into some action here hey late to
the party what's going on buddy that's
right you've divided our fan base here
that's that's what it but people some
people really agree with you some people
don't combo way it goes it's the way it
goes man that's fandom for youall yeah
it's people it's not just fandom it's
it's Humanity like we are all we all
aren't going to like the same things I
don't like eggs or Mayo right you may
love egg and Mayo this channel is free
we literally been responding to comments
here the whole time going off of what
you guys are saying let's go into so I
want to see what was going on in the if
you jop someone off their thumbnails is
that not what they're trying to
advertise their channel is about that is
what they they're putting that out as
what they
are I love how this is spiraled just
it's so easy to be angry at the internet
um let's talk about something positive
speaking of positivity there is no
positivity Coy there's no posit okay
while I'm loading these uh what did you
watch Invincible season 2 uh I haven't
yet I started it and I fell asleep and I
was like this is not the way to watch
what a terrible plug well no it wases
you supposed to be Shilling no I
literally 2 minutes and I was like oh no
I I fell asleep minutes for something
this good what did you just say I was 4
in the morning and I was like we got a
stream tomorrow I need to watch this and
I was like this is not how I want to
watch are you falling asleep at 4 in the
morning so tired Greg that's probably
why I'm grumpy today um but yeah no I
really want to watch it today look at my
legs
oo he went for a hike they're toned
they're seasoned also to see all the
comments at the beginning is like look
how good Greg shape is in and that's
true cuz he's been hiking look how good
Greg shape he's been wearing a weighted
vest he's been crushing I need to I need
to refresh this I want to watch
invisble but okay well I saw Invincible
season 2 episode one and um I'll tell
you man without spoiling anything for
you guys because I know I think the
release dates of everything has been
real odd I don't know what's going on
with Studios I don't understand to have
a finale the same day as a Premiere I'm
like for for a day and age where there's
a a constant conversation about
superhero for fatigue like the it's not
a good idea for everyone to release
everything all at once it's just not a
good idea because if you spread it out
it won't feel as fatigas if that's a
word fatigas it won't it won't feel as
um just uh a bombastic and a cacophony
of comic book properties and it it it
dilutes the appreciation per individual
property I feel to do that and a lot of
people might go ah I just watch watch
gen V and Loki do I really want to start
up Invincible right now because
Invincible to me is one of the best
superhero shows that has ever existed I
love it and I think this I rewatched
season one over the past couple of weeks
and then I I started season two and I I
really think it is a solid follow-up if
it's melancholic it's character driven
the first the premiere like watching
season one brought me back to because I
don't I didn't know the comics like you
yeah yeah and watching the first episode
was really interesting because it
reminded me of my experience the first
time I saw that episode which you can
catch here on the channel was I I I
watched I watched it I was like I don't
get what the hype is about this show
because it just kind of feels like a DC
animated show kid-friendly and
then the ending gets insanely violent I
was like oh yeah that brilliant shock
value cuz the book is so like what is
happening and then the show managed to
do that with a different pace yeah and
then I and then watching this season uh
if you guys haven't started it I know
people are just getting around it so I
don't want to go into details about it
it's really great and a solid it only
takes place a month after the first
season it's setting up new things that I
find very exciting does it play with
timeline like the first season did uh
not exactly the trailers did reveal that
they will be dealing with the Multiverse
and already they're doing it in a way
that feels more compelling than a lot of
things we've gotten that have dealt with
Multiverse cool yeah there's a lot of
multiversal stuff with especially one
villain in the particular okay I I
assume that'll be this season's choice
and I I I think stevenh Yun as Mark
Grayson is such an underrecognized
people always talk about like JK Simmons
as omn man because of the character of
omn man but Stephen yun's performance as
as Mark Grayson is so good in uh you
know Thunderbolts which I think is gonna
be interesting and Sterling K Brown also
is um is is in uh Whatchamacallit uh
Browns in season one of the I got it I
don't want man I love him but he's a
main new character amazing that's just
that's the commercial that's all I need
to know but yeah if you guys have not
caught Invincible season 2 please go
check it out I I it's a massive
endorsement for me I've only seen the
first episode know other people have
already seen the first uh four or yeah
because they divided into two parts or
something like that I'm uh I'm twitching
uh I just want to see it awake um
because it is like a more somber opening
and like I really am excited to see that
like you don't want to watch something
when you're exhausted that isn't
fast-paced so I'm really excited to
watch it like in an afternoon yes yes I
agree anyway let's get this off uh I
just want to thank some super chats that
coming here um thank you guys who have
who are contributing the super chats
means we have streamlabs as well right
now I know some people get mad when you
do a live stream and then people you get
super just like all they talk about is
part of YouTube it's a part of twitch
accept it man and we will and we will
just go about we are we have to chat up
here for for a reason and we did 20
minutes of and I have ADHD this helps us
diagnosed ADHD true so we know how to uh
process multiple things at once it's
one strengths of ADHD it actually is
there's a lot of weaknesses but this two
screens is nice um let's see
here Dart Carr thank you so much for
kicking off the super chats he's saying
how's it going it's going well happy to
be back doing a live stream uh we
haven't done a live stream in a while
when was three months ago August I think
so yeah speaking of speaking of live
Dart car uh I'm I'm trying to plan for I
want to do a real reject live event you
know oh dude I'd love that we had
ComicCon which went great Bo it was was
there for the last I made a cameo in the
thing I tried to organize we have Wonder
con I've done a couple of live events at
Flappers and I want to do a real reject
live event where all of us where all all
of us are in all of us know how to do
live shows and I and I think live live
event of us is very different than what
you might expect yeah I say way
more yeah also like you can see like
people's faces to names I love seeing
like random screen names and meeting
them being like Oh my God it's you I
love Live Events we are live dicks uh we
will go going into some loky season 2
The in a second Alex Donovan glad to be
here love the Echo trailer thank you for
the Super Chat my friend uh yeah the
Echo trailer co and I were even talking
about a little bit after couldn't
believe how good it was yeah I think
it's the first trailer in a while we
both like finished filming and then like
went into it more because they were like
what just happened the the my my
Thursday in particular was so much
editing I was editing like I don't know
I must have edited for like eight nine
hours that day on top of filming
F do and and then see what's under the
ice like like that's why I don't run my
YouTube page I just post shorts because
what Greg does is you see this much and
it takes all of this that's why my
YouTube is justice but the the three it
was like 3: or 4 in the morning I was
going to bed and I texted Coy like I'm
going to try to wake up and I'll let you
know because I had I really had no
interest in covering the Echo trailer
yeah I brought it up he's like that's
tomorrow with such like a okay and then
I called him I'm like hey man it's out
let's just come over I was like screw it
cuz cuz I have anything to put together
on YouTube admittedly we don't do them
as often anymore no but admittedly a
trailer reaction is much shorter put
together than like a TV or movie
reaction right and I told him right
after like that woke me up what was
great was usually like we used to do
just trailers like five a week because
it was so much more like midnights and
9:00 a.m. and 6:00 a.m. and usually it'd
be like okay wake up at 6:00 a.m. and be
here and I was always like oh God and it
was so hard and this time it was like
9:00 a.m. casually just like I'll get in
the car get over here and then as soon
as we sat down within 10 seconds of the
actual trailer it was like I'm so glad
we changed our entire day to make this
work cuz we had no intention of actually
covering it and I think that's why a lot
of the channels didn't cover it but I
think that also speaks to this tone of
the Marvel like brand right now it's not
the event it was like a Marvel trailer
was like you plan your week around it
this one was like we'll get to it and
then when we did it felt special again
it felt like the Netflix trailers it
felt big and important so I'm really
hoping the show is the trailer well see
some I've seen this comic going around a
lot too someone in the chat just said
see we talking about what's going on in
the chat oh are we guys gez people say
we don't is that I just lost it but
someone just pointed out pay attention
oh no I lost someone just pointed
out
how secret Invasion trailer look good
this and and we say it towards the end
of our video uh you know a lot of people
might not stick around for the full
trailer review portion which is much
longer than the reaction portion so I
get it is that my concern with this I
didn't say because like secret Invasion
trailer was good because a trailer can
just be a great trailer and I think a
trailer is so important to selling
something more than Rotten Tomatoes or
anything there's an argument to be made
for that a lot of people think it's
Rotten Tomatoes I I honestly believe
it's it's a trailer yeah I I A lot of
times I feel like Ron tomato doesn't
mean jack um as long as the trailer
is good enough to attract the fan base
are looking to attract because everyone
went I'm not going to watch it too oh my
God yeah with a trailer like because you
have to over the the MCU fans and even
the fans of MCU who had no interest in
it especially and that is kind of the
conversation where I was like wow this
actually looks really good so they might
have actually gathered their fan base so
even if it's crap even if that's the
reason why they're releasing it all at
once is because they don't have faith in
it maybe who knows I heard the better
call S riters are involved in it I've
heard the people who worked on the
Daredevil show are involved in it some
me really excited uh remind us someone
in the chat anyone remind us to talk
about what they said about ekko's Powers
not being the same did you read about
that I did but it doesn't bother me
we'll talk about it yeah we'll talk
about it I will say that uh yeah while
the secret Invasion trailer did look
really great and the show ended up being
lackluster it's a very different kind of
trailer at the same time in a different
show it's it it doesn't feel like the
same thing at all and then you hear
about the way they approach this one
with getting chock top people involved
um with really f w with just as actual
narrative that they're telling it's a
very different story and it doesn't see
where secret Invasion seem interested in
also setting up a bigger part of the MCU
this does not yeah it feels like it's in
and that the Marvel Spotlight thing that
just got announced did you see that yeah
so I think that's going to be really
important for Marvel going forward I
mean i' I've been saying for five years
that I hope DC doesn't try to make
everything connected you can have an
overarching thing but if it's all
mandatory you'll have the Marvel problem
and you won't get to play so I love the
idea that Marvel's gonna finally get to
play and have things that are in the
universe but not mandatory viewing or
have things that can connect but don't
have to and I think a Marvel Spotlight
is going to allow a certain tone I think
between Ekko being tvma and Deadpool
being R-rated we're seeing that they are
letting the universe mature I think it's
all very ve like these steps are all the
steps you need to do if your universe is
stagnating alrighty Christopher
whof Christopher whma Champion we have
never ever gotten a super chat this this
is beyond generous and it's funny that
you just sent this super chat in because
I did see your Instagram message I won't
go into the details of what the
Instagram messenger was about I just saw
it this morning as I today was the first
day I got sleep in a few weeks I took I
had to take a a medication pill to sleep
but I got sleep and I was going through
my message requests and uh Chris Chris
has been someone who has been part of
our patreon page for a very long time
I've gotten to know him he's been on the
news because he's one of those people
who fights the good fight he's been
arrested for fighting the good fight
he's he's uh he he he likes to go
against the injustices that are dealt
with other people he's he's a an
extremely obviously from here you can
see he's a generous guy but he has
helped contribute to people's lives in
more ways than people who are on YouTube
you know people who are really truly in
need like this is very generous we are
not necessarily in need of there are
people who are really struggling out
there and Chris Roff is one of those
people who really goes out of his way to
get Hands-On and involved with that so
to see that you are going to share this
generosity our way for people are not as
much of a need of it of obviously uh
that means a lot dude and uh thank you
for being such a such a strong supporter
for a very very very very very long time
thank you so much um yeah I gotta I'll
reply back to you as soon as the stream
is done dude uh Robert presser Prius sir
thank you for the Super Chat says have a
great weekend I hope so man I'd like
that got to catch up on some stuff I
have been playing Spider-Man 2
officially oh I'm so jealous I'm turning
my phone off as soon as the stream is
done I'm going to go to the movie
theater and just watch stuff like killer
the flower Moon whatever else is next
there you go cannot wait to just have a
veg Day Christian unpronouncable welcome
back good to see your name again
Christian Louis Barry oh this gives us
an opportunity to talk about one of our
main topics here Lou I don't know what
the limit is on Super Chat donations
someone just asked I was like I didn't
know as high is that I didn't know that
that's kind of insane thank you uh Louis
Barry can't wait for Loki finale and I
think we're getting Thor and Deadpool
setting up Deadpool 3 in the King
Dynasty thank you for the Super Chat uh
the Loki finale koi what are your
predictions on how this is going to end
the only I my feel like my predictions
are less than so if you don't mind me
just quick quickly saying I think let me
ask you a question and then stop you and
then say it because my predictions are
so obvious because I was thinking it
before the end of last episode obviously
set it up yeah that they are going to be
doing and I think I said during the
credits of of our reaction was that it's
going to be a bit of
a you know what it's more like I think
the easiest way to to latch your brains
around it is there's doramu the the
doramu situation or the doctor strange
wha if episode when he's just constantly
trying to save
uh yeah or or in the OR in that episode
where he's trying to save Christine
Palmer you know and there's this episode
actually in Doctor Who the Peter Capaldi
season where yeah he's just trying to
get out of this situation he's trapped
in and he's there for like a million
years or something like that and and I
think that's and while and Loki has
often been compared to Doctor Who it's
like the the more hyper fast-paced
version of a doctor who a little bit
more diluted for a Doctor Who's way more
complicated and and I think that's what
we're going to be dealing that whole
season is going to be a big episode of
them just repeating that over and over
and like a crazy time Loop but where do
you think it's going to end okay so I
think it's going to end with basically
Kang being in control of everything
that's happened I think that at some
point we're going to find out that he
wanted Victor timley to get whether or
not that imbued the kangs with power
whether or not that Gave Victor timley
some sort of control of time I think
that that his getting Mom spaghetti was
very conscious I think that that was a
path that he set him on as soon as that
book got handed we have two Ora Boris
happening we've got the OB Loki Ora
Boris and we've got the Ora Boris and
Kang Ora Boris and I think that all
those things have been manipulated by he
who remains Kang from the jump so I
think we're going to end season two
episode six with very much a okay this
is how powerful this character is look
at what he was able to do against the
god of stories because Loki at the end
of episode 5 is the god of stories in
Marvel Comics Loki went from the god of
Mischief to the god of stories and that
was kind of their way of making him more
of a positive figure more of a um he's
still mischievous but he's more
benevolent and I think basically now
we've got Loki in this very powerful
role like he's able to basically control
SpaceTime he can manipulate stories but
he's doing it benevolently I think
they're going to show how strong Kang is
by having him overpower Loki to be like
hey you just saw this character you've
had since season one level up look at
how strong Kang is I think it's a great
way to like show a power Dynamic kind of
like they did with the Infinity Stones
like look how strong this world is the
Infinity Stones have been nullified by
the power of the TVA so I think likewise
that's going to be Kang's Arc at the end
is we we're going to meet a more
powerful Kang uh I do think there's
going to be a bit of that timey wiy uh I
do think there's going to be um you know
the come to bargain concept but I think
that by the end Loki is in some way
running the TVA like people think king
of TVA people think him behind that desk
I think that's possible but I do think
we're going to see him um as the god of
stories and I think that's a good way to
use him or not going forward I think
that whether Tom Heston wants to play in
the greater MCU or not that's a perfect
way to have your cake and eat it too
like he can come back or he's tucked
away over there so uh God of stories
element Kang being uh in control of the
Victor timely choice and all those
things and I would say um we we do see
uh a bit more of a uh powered Loki in
the finale I really feel like we're
going to get the reveal to that this has
been all we've been watching in season
two has been he who remains his big play
I defin think so cuz camera angles the
voyerism the the style of timing like
the moment in episode five where Loki
was able to kind of time Jump himself in
that little tiny bit of control that
still felt like he was being watched and
I still feel like that was Kang going
like hey do this hey do this so I think
that's what's coming I think what you
have definitely done is hopefully given
nerd nerd rodic whoever at least never
seen any of his videos I hope they able
to clip this out I mean there's so many
videos of me Shilling for the Marvels
that have been clipped out by people
that hate women so by all means one
channel that Clips out everyone and um
yeah it's I just wish I had the time
they have to edit just go thanks for the
promotion like they have more time to
edit than I have time to edit my own
videos so I'm just jealous of their free
time a lot of I what I've seen happen a
lot with our Channel which I find really
really funny like we're a channel that
is often easy to judge off of a
thumbnail and the fact that we do
reactions sure I'm really proud of this
Channel and especially this this year
quite a bit I'm very proud of this
channel of what we've been able to
really transition into what our main
focus has been we have more variety I
think 100% like even though like we
mainly do reactions I'm talking about
like in terms of genre of what we cover
and honestly like the videos take a most
of our videos take quite a long time to
they take many hours to put together but
people often think just because we have
the word reaction there that it's that
that's all this it's a lazy Channel you
know I'm like upad if you I can
guarantee you it's it's the furthest
thing from laer from the way we
construct just because the word reaction
is are like what one thing that I I'll
go into it a little bit later I had a
whole rant that I did not post on this
channel
but I'm uh but yeah but thank you for
the Super Chat Alex Alex thank you Alex
my friend
um I love how this chat is so it's so
you you have kicked off something so
insane it's given us SEO right it's G
maybe I don't know if it helps a play
back it's fun to watch you guys uh
interact with each other I saw people
defend like defending Ben Shapiro and I
was like this is not my audience I don't
know how this happened some people love
love what you yes some people love this
some people don't uh I'm embarrassing
myself here by not liking people that
hate women who do I think I am uh let's
see here Alex hey Coy really enjoyed
your interview with Yuri would love to
see more of those well we got one in the
can that we shot there's a comp I won't
say who it is but I can I can tell you
some details there's one that we shot
pre- strike you'll see Coy looks very
different it was months ago not as in
shape and also much more hair and but
then a sag strike happened and it and it
it created a massive confusion and we
just want to respect the actor he's a
actor who he's a quite a respected actor
I'll say I'll keep it that like that um
and but right now we can't post it even
though we a shot pre- strike we resp we
want to respect the choice of the actor
I cannot wait last we want to do is do
another follow-up episode and just piss
off someone guys we have another episode
no other actors want to come on the show
said you said you said we shut we yeah
and yeah there's other one when the SAG
strike is over we're hoping to really
keep that as like a a minimum a monthly
thing and then graduate to a bi-weekly
then a weekly and then yeah if you guys
want more of those uh also let us know
in the comments of that video If there's
people you'd want to see uh if you guys
want to see more of those please do
share it tag us on socials I'll like
reshare your shares because that's the
way we know that's something you want so
seeing it here is is already amazing so
thank you but I do basically I I do a
lot of cons for work like I I talk to
people that you know we love the art of
and I want to do that for you guys so we
need to know that that's what you want
so let us know and share and comment at
stuff yeah yeah is it Roxy what about
Roxy I don't know what Roxy did oh yeah
I interviewed Roxy and we gotta hold it
can't let that go uh oh I do like this
pick and I'll tell you why Laura why I
think Matt Smith is there is no second
part to Yuri's yet but he wants a two
through seven so it's probably a thing
Robert prer says again thank you for the
Super Chat my friend what is under your
guys Comfort movies oh I really love
Wild Wild West right now I'm in the
comfort shows I've been watching uh
Whose Line is at anyway respect really
been loving who Lin is anyway just
revisiting that and that's been my
comfort show what do you have a comfort
movie or com show night's tail is a big
one for me a nights tail gets on a lot
uh morat's big one for me uh I'm a big
Lethal Weapon guy I put on Lethal Weapon
fairly often oh like Halloween movies
like Lost Boys And the crow every time I
watch Lost Boys or the crow I feel like
feel like a kid again like I'm so
settled into like my my whole childhood
uh and then shows wise I don't really
rewatch TV a lot like it's so many hours
I love just casual TV I haven't it's
been watch since I watched like a good
drama on TV honestly I I really can't do
casual like TV or movies well like I
except if I watch it as a kid like I
don't I don't enjoy background stuff
like I I can't really mess with reality
TV or like I don't know it just doesn't
it doesn't tickle that that like oh I
iom fancy yeah like like baking shows I
don't get it uh Dan v900 thank you so
much for the Super Chat thank you the
second to last episode D Patrol dropped
on Thursday alongside everything else
all right well I need to catch I am like
way behind on Doom Patrol the one weird
thing from the Variety article is the
idea they pivot from King literally the
easiest character to
recast I think the part of it of I mean
a yeah we've had a lot of discussions
about it I don't agree with the idea I'm
just put this out there of turning
ravona into a into King I don't I don't
I've heard this many times I don't agree
with this at all I think that would
upset people that sounds very Pander
version definitely does and and uh just
narrative wise there's a version you
could kind of see it working they're
just copying the plot of of season one
where it's like that's your variant but
then you're you're removing raona at
that point the actual raona storyline
even more so and Kang loving raona is
part of what kicks off the impetus of
him being the Conqueror yeah exactly so
uh I don't I don't like that I think you
can recast Kang if you need to come down
to it
and sure maybe quantam Mania was not but
that okay here's the interesting thing
about the perspective Ive if Marvel
really is having a bit of a fraught
situation with Kang uh going should we
even even before jonan M legal problems
if we should steer away from King
because not enough people show up for
quantam Mania that's the problem with
Marvel right there is they didn't focus
on making an Ant-Man movie right if all
their eggs in the basket were on to
promote King the Conqueror and not
enough people showed up for that and
then they went okay well no that's
Kang's problem that is the problem
Marvel it is it's not King necessarily
it's how you're going about your
introduction with king or trying to
emphasize or build him up you know like
how they introduced him in Loki was
brilliant because there was all this
emphasis on who was behind the TVA
that's the entire emphasis of season 1
leading to its final 20 minutes is you
find out the truth of the TVA you find
out who the real Creator is and that's
what made King menacing and so scary and
this ultimate threat and it's not the
answer wasn't put him in Quantum media
and then judge and then do an algorithm
data metric breakdown and then decide
it's like suits making audiences are not
interested k e v i n but actually it's
like an algorithm of Kevin fogy not
Kevin fogy getting to say it it's a
terrible way to judge if that is the way
to base uh if if Kang is the way to go
forward now the other side of it is
doing Secret Wars without Doom seems odd
because because he's such a fundamental
part of battle world and Secret Wars and
Secret Wars yeah like he's fundamental
to all the secret ORS like there's three
different runs of secret ORS so I do
think Doom is coming I do think Kang is
in a tricky spot um I've heard you know
some interesting ideas about recasting
that do work for me uh especially with
certain shows getting canceled um it
seems like a show that I was really
looking forward to because the lead
actor got cancelled and he would be an
excellent Kang but they they are in a
tricky spot um because they don't really
if if they cancel this version of Kang
and then it turns out that the Jonathan
major accusations are unfounded and they
have you know absolute proof of his
innocence they're in a messy spot and
they're in a messy spot if he's proven
guilty and and then they have an actor
that is the title card of Avengers 5 so
they're really in a rock and a hard
place and at the end of the day these
are movies and it's way more important
that Justice is served for whatever
happens in the real world so I see why
there in it's just such a messy spot
because it's an entire universe
surrounding one
situation I'm hoping for OB was beyonder
maybe I do people have been asking about
this in the chat a lot I it will be
interesting for this version of Loki to
meet Thor I would love to see a an
emotionally uh mature Loki like a
therapized Loki to meet Thor because I
think it'd be great closure for like
Papa Thor you know cuz he's in a
different place in his life it'd be
great closure for Loki who just wants to
be loved and I think think this is a
lovable Loki and his relationship with
Mobius shows he's more trustworthy um so
I'd love that it'd be it'd be like this
is us as guardian Edition Sam spring
thank you Sam spring for the Super Chat
love you too buddy love your thumbnail
that's a great thumbnail can you guys
see that is it on the is it on the
screen yeah do you like this framing you
see I adjusted the framing I adjusted
everything like how much bigger that is
of the super chats that they're
highlighted and then you also have the
way perfectly split yeah and then they
can see the chat when we catch the joh
was helping me out with it last night of
just figuring out like how do we how do
we crop everything yeah so that way
looks better when people are doing you
see the three very different Vibes I'm
into it Dak chats thank you so much my
friend are you going to do any more
video games like Survivor you know I got
a lot of crap for just doing uh I mean
they still landed like 97 98% likes so
it's not that bad but I I definitely saw
the negativity it spurred up in a
Twitter threat about him while when I
was just covering the cut scenes for
Spider-Man PS2 too like I I covered all
the cut scenes which had some gameplay
in there to help enhance story and now
and then this past week on some downtime
I've taken like an
hour some days out of the week to just
play Spider-Man 2 before I go to bed so
instead of watching TV to to relax and
like we just play some Spider-Man 2 and
I maybe clocked in in total like five
hours and I've only just finished part
one of the cut scenes reaction who so I
was like you know what I'm glad I there
was no way to get it out I just don't
have I when I said I didn't have the
time like people don't realize how much
like editing Five Nights at Freddy movie
reaction and making the thumb like that
the edit for that took me like like
almost nine hours yeah people don't
realize
that I can't sacrifice the whole Channel
just to cover one guys everything's on
pause no Invincible reactions nothing
coming out no news and a lot of times
two people don't realize that yeah we
have we'll have like prepper team who
helps us edit um but we're also very
much involved with the re-editing and
you know like that that's very timec
consuming as well so like if all we did
was film yeah of course I'd have the
time but but
I really not the reality of the
situation um Dak chat uh so one of these
days I would like to I would it would be
great to be in a position one day where
it could be the thing is when I game too
I am such a quiet gamer yes I'm like
actually in it's not like being reacted
to even yesterday I asked my my wife
like hey you're she's like watching
on Tik Tok why don't you to watch out
here while I'm playing games and we
could talk talk and I would just I have
the hard just hone in I hone in I go
quiet I I all my anger stays internal I
rarely but when I do I'm like in a
meditative State like that's exactly
what I say that's why I like racing CU I
can like it literally feels like
meditation the idea of doing with a
camera point on me and streaming I'm
like I don't know if I'd enjoy that also
reactions are so dependent on my like
energy level and mood like when we did
the Loki 5 episode the comments are so
mad at me for talking so much but it was
because like it was my ninth thing of
the day day like I'd already done two
shows I'd already filmed a bunch of
Socials and i' gone to the dentist so I
was like Twitchy like needing to have
energy expunged I don't I'm not like
that in gaming though because that needs
to be my time to like the energy is here
in the thumbs
yeah um now I like when you talk gives
me something to cut away to since we can
only use six to seven seconds at a time
helping my ego we need the commentary
plus it helps us show that we're doing
commentary Bron's alive Magnus and rodic
Magnus and rodic you you you know me
well I I I gladly check out I mean it's
not me promoting neur I don't I've never
seen a neurotic video I've heard him
referenced before and I I really don't I
just know his thumbnails are enough to
know that so actually I want to bring
while we're here uh there's a few people
in the chat that keep saying like
doesn't mean hate women I I'm saying
that like if you hate women you're not
going to like the Marvels but you might
not like the Marvels even if you don't
hate women I'm saying there's a VIN
diagram where that is a very strong
contingent and that seems obvious if you
make your thumbnail who whoever you are
about the MCU or complaining about women
I'm assuming you've got a problem with
women but that doesn't mean that's why
you don't like the Marvels but I I do
think there's no way you'll like the
Marvels it's very obvious and I think
you're being intentionally daed a few of
you but that's not what I'm saying and I
think you know it I just think you want
to be angry and hey therapy's gotten
less expensive look into it uh let's see
here Dan v900 thank you again Dan v900
last year Chad selski said
uh I've seen your reaction some Mel
Brooks comedies I did uh Blazing Saddles
Dan v900 last year Chad house said he
wanted to do an edgy R-rated blade film
and spoke to feige after John week 3 uh
but they wanted to protect the brand
with Echo Bean tvma just do it go back
to him ASAP you know I think with all
the controversy blade has garnered with
the and and it's very apparent it's in
disarray when you announce Mersa Aldi
being blade with bringing the house down
that that was your mic drop moment yeah
at at that
ComicCon short I believe it was shortly
after him winning an
Oscar you know it was Mike dropped Fade
to
Black this is what happens with Marvel
and herit fox how great is that you know
and it's been so many years yeah it's so
apparent there's problems happening it's
very very apparent there's problems
happening with blade I really think they
would win and blade is exciting to be in
the MCU because most of us don't know
blade from the comics you got to be real
with yourself most of us don't know
blade from the comics most of us know
from a really popular film franchise
that existed prior yeah which was which
wasn't advertised as a comic because
most people didn't know blade from the
comic even then it wasn't like a comic
movie I think a way to
Garner um a positive conversation around
blade I I never say I hope Marvel's
listen I never say that this is the one
this is one of the few I hope Marvel's
listening one few times I hope they're
listening I think a way to save blad's
reputation prior to all with all this
coming out is make it R-rated yeah
I think that would totally change the
conversation around what happened with
eeko within 24 hours Ekko went from that
property that we heard only bad things
about that seemingly got dumped in a one
bing streak and now all of a sudden it's
like wait they made something that we've
been asking for it looks totally
different it's on Hulu too like you do
that with blade and also the importance
of blade blade to me is the thing that
really kicked off Marvel Comics in movie
theaters Spider-Man got a lot of a claim
X-Men was obviously hugely important
there's a reason it's a franchise but
blade was in 98 blade preceded The
Matrix blade was literally like all the
badass dark trench coat slow-mo before
the Matrix blade was hugely influential
and then two years later we got X-Men
three years after blade we got
Spider-Man blade to me is The Unsung
like OG
he he's Rizza like right like hip-hop
got huge but Rizza was making beats that
inspired Wu Tang's like ultimate success
obviously he's a part of wuang too but
that led to hip-hop in the modern sense
he didn't invent hip-hop but blade to me
is the invention of the modern superhero
film and it did it without talking about
the comics it did it without being
interconnected to a shared universe but
it really planted those seeds so to me
blade needs to come out swinging as good
or better than anything else because
it's a Legacy character for comic movies
and to me it's kind of the sister to um
X-Men like Kevin fogy sure sure was so
integral to making the X-Men work like
he was on set he was a producer way back
with like the Lauren Scher Doner days he
was so important to that I think that's
why it's so important to Kevin figy to
get the gmen right and I think that
likewise blade needs to be just as
important so blade and X-Men I think are
the big comeback of everyone loving
Marvel to scale again well that say this
com from me on who's been U an immense
supporter of our Channel and and I don't
mean this I I'm just acknowledging a
point that I know some people are making
here I don't want this to sound like I'm
arguing with you because I'm really not
uh Deadpool 3 is already rated R that's
not the same thing as making blade rated
R because Deadpool 3 is it's it is a
sequel to an already already R-rated
franchise this would be something new
yes a reboot yes whatever so it's not
100% new at the end of the day it will
be new within the MCU for a new
franchise yeah they're just inheriting a
sequel
with deadpol 3 they're inheriting a
franchise this is a this is a new
franchise for the MCU with blade and it
it speaks a different volume when if you
were to start off a new franchise with
that as oppos to just keeping the sequel
going because yeah Deadpool 3 is just a
completely different kind of film I
think that's why Ekko is such a big
impact is it's tvma and it's new so
right right that feels bigger than maybe
even I mean I think when Daredevil gets
announced as the new iteration it should
be TVM but I think Ekko being a new new
character speaks loudly for what they're
trying to do Deadshot thank you so much
Deadshot um glad to see you back on
stream I'm very excited with Ekko and
it's what I've been saying on I believe
show movies range should depend on the
characters or story you are making a th%
with with what we just talked about our
rating grittiness does not equate to
good it doesn't yeah you know ask the
2000s when everything was greedy and
edgy and all rated secret Invasion uh
would go a little bit harsher in moments
than you might expect yeah didn't equate
to good show Hellboy was rebooted for an
R rating didn't equate to a better movie
than the deloro versions there's a
couple people on this channel haven't
seen the deloro movies I found out yo
react no way yeah yeah um yeah so I I
don't think it equates to that I'm
hoping eeko is good I you know it's the
narrative around it preceding all reing
its trailer debut is concerning it it is
yeah you know it seems like there is a
lack of faith to go from weekly to
dumping and it just sounds like they
kind of want people to forget about it
moving it to
January which is just kind of associated
with being a month yeah um even
though the conversation's slightly
changing around that but for the longest
time it has
been so yeah I but I I hope it's good
and glad to see back on stream yeah I
love I I we haven't streamed in in a
while but I love streaming you know the
thing is like when we're editing the
dude that was bothering me because I
thought he had an opinion is defending
cat
calling wow like that's a very strong
whataboutism I literally was like maybe
maybe I've offended someone that has an
opinion worth acknowledging and then he
said that and I was like this person
doesn't even Merit breathing that's a
weird that's a weird weird you were this
is such a strange one about is cat
calling worse than being hunted by
military well is being harassed and
assaulted better than being dead I think
so I just like I felt I started to feel
bad because they seem so offended by my
like my worldview and I was starting to
be like maybe I am getting a little like
like too tribal in my thinking and then
this guy says this I like I feel way
better immediately oh God thank you
Skyler for making me feel better about
myself uh sorry I interrupted that was
amazing that that's really that's really
funny
um made me so
happy okay um but yes I'm happy to be
streaming and with Nick Alexander thank
you so much for this Super Chat as well
sorry Co we do have to move on no no I'm
so sorry I'm like Gul I have missed
these live streams can't listen now but
we'll catch it later think probably Nick
Alexander I hope you catch up we reading
your super chat right now thank you um
yeah no especially a big part of um
doing doing um the the videos is a lot
of times when I'm fil when I'm filming
especially for my end uh with everyone
everyone else here they mainly just have
to focus on being on camera and I try to
I've been lately letting the other hosts
be a little bit aware of of how the
editing goes like we I like that we have
the commentary during the reactions and
then I kind of encourage it a little bit
more you know to speak more what's on
your mind and and the thing is when I'm
filming I have to simultaneously be
completely committed to two places at
once be in the moment so I can express
how I'm feeling and thinking of based
off whatever we're watching if we're
doing a reaction yeah if it's a reaction
specifically secondly I'm thinking about
the edit yeah that's hard to be present
and also in the future and then so doing
a live stream is is essentially a live
podcast where it's very interactive with
you guys so I I love theot I I
personally love doing live streams yeah
and uh so I want to do a live show again
which very is the live show has become
like a live show which is so funny to me
because it's Greg in the beginning was
like I don't know like is the live thing
like the right thing like it wasn't like
he was against it but there was
definitely like an apprehension and each
time we do one I see Greg like light up
a little bit more and now like to hear
him be like let's do one like he him
being proactive makes me so happy CU
like Greg is so good with so it makes me
so happy that he's now he's like I don't
have to convince him he's like this is
what I want makes me I appreciate and
yeah you know KY was one of the big uh
champions for us doing Live Events and I
was very as a matter of fact I'll tell
you guys you know for those who saw the
podcast he did With Yuri when we were
first doing test setups with the with
Mike and it was a very different set and
uh we were doing test setups and
everything uh we were like let's just
shoot a test and it's like 20 minutes
long and it's Coy trying to convince me
to do wonder and I because I didn't want
to do WonderCon and I WonderCon has been
one of the highlights of the year and I
really didn't want to do WonderCon and
it's co like actively convincing me on
camera to do one Recon that that was
when you decided I saw the shift on fo
was like fine I'll do it whatever oh man
now once we start doing lives that'll be
the trailer for him uh Nico
Hotel I know we got super chat like
we're at the top here I know we got more
but uh we're going to take a a tiny
little bit of a break here not not a
break from the stream niik Odell yall
seen the cookie thank you for the Super
Chat yall seen the cooking show pressure
cooker on Netflix one contestant Mike
has to be related to koi they talk
similarly and sound like cousins you
know I've never met someone who I
thought this reminds me of koi jandre I
haven't seen it yet I uh I look I um
I've my my like manic Cadence and my
like my brain is just really loud and I
feel like I'm like a record skipping
like I I I don't assemble sentences or
phrase things in a way I've never met
anyone else do there's occasionally
people with my mania like I think
Jonathan Tucker in certain roles feels
like me and I think that like certain
people occasionally look like me but I'm
always fascinated by seeing the people
that remind people of me because then I
watch it I'm like is that what I'm like
to some people so I will check this
fellow out and I I appreciate the uh the
love mellow Willow what's up buddy I
don't think I've seen your name here
before whoa now that bye gets you
banned
coside mellow Willow that's where I like
that that's where we both draw the line
oh yeah that's that's my comfort show I
watch friends but you could I mean it's
all I my comfort show is friends I forg
I would I've been wanting to put on
friends yeah um I haven't found it's a
little bit hard for me right now I've
been watching a lot of bloopers um I'm
just going to cry the whole time I just
know me too well now to know I'm just
going to cry the whole time that might
be what helps though yeah like the
bloopers have been helping me because
it's I get to see little moments of him
and Chandler intermixed and that's been
helpful but yeah that's my comfort I
could do a whole podcast about why
friends is so important in my life like
Beyond Chandler being but like but
Chandler's Journey specifically out of
any charact he's one of the characters
who grew the most in ways that were kind
of subtle throughout the I won't go into
no no I'm saying that like he's a
character who really grew a lot andout
it and and even my personal life growth
is is more out of any friend's character
is more a k to his right yeah so that
was one of the first things you and I
talked about ever yeah you and I on on
screen Junkies you and I talked about
friends like eight years ago that's a
really nice compliment Jay thank you um
mellow Willow Real rejects effing Rock
for eggs and
Mayo yes F eggs and Mayo what what am I
missing a am I missing a joke here oh
when I said earlier EG and Mayo are
gross oh
okay yes I missed that FX and Mayo
indeed melow Willow I appreciate you oh
dude Coy check out check out this thing
that John and I figured out yesterday
speed up switching this I saw we got
some
streamlabs oh look at that buddy ah
before streamlabs whoa what happened to
the chat what happened to the chat that
I hit the wrong button uh oh you were
like oh bad sorry didn't didn't make you
guys go away uh we do have a a really
generous streamlab one here from Gan
Jeter TV oh my God let me shout it out
let me shout out Gan Jeter TV uh he
recently um put together a crazy YouTube
video that is on his YouTube channel
it's a Halloween one uh let me get the
exact title here I make sure I don't
want to botch this uh John you linked it
wrong man just goes to his channel it's
supposed to go to the video on the
channel John please what have you
done
John the only one here that can defend
himself epic party you only go after
people that they're not around to defend
themselves that's the way you win ask
anyone in the live CH he says thank you
guys well thank you buddy go check out
his YouTube channel he's a very
experimental artist uh needless to say
strange eccentric choices a lot of
oddities uh but overall an extremely
extremely nice guy and I I love a nice
artist more than anyone else in a day
where you're constantly in combat with a
lot of Egos and wondering do I want to
engage do I do I want to do this right
now or do I just yes and and move on
with my life to get the out of this
conversation because that is uh that
that is how most of my days go yeah let
me see here liking things is cool not
it's not as cool as it used to be but uh
it is cool that is a bold uh a live
stream with the whole reject team that
is that's probably a live event cuz I
don't know if we have enough space or
mics yeah Zim I know there's channels
that call this dis I've heard my whole
life uh Lone Wolf and I know about the
channel you're talking about what they
call I appreciate the promotion what I
wanted to say about I forgot what
they're called you were on a tangent
what is that channel called um name it
down Bel I know some some of you guys
must know what that channel is is there
a Channel about the real reject Channel
no no no it's it's that thing that you
were lumped into with the what what they
Gob something like that what they like
clip out like reactors and call them
shills and all that stuff oh yeah I was
so honored man yeah yeah well the the
the funny thing about that channel in
particular or stuff like that I've seen
it happen many times not all the time a
lot of people will just judge us off our
thumbnail a lot of people might just
judge us fact we I judge people off
their thumbnail because it is an
assessment of the channel yeah and
people will do that with us thinking
like all videos are exactly the same or
that we instantly like something a lot
of times I'm like a thumbnail might make
it look that way but it's really just
the biggest
it's the biggest expression so that's
why I chose it but uh but no a lot of
the time though uh that I've seen people
go you know I came here people talk
about you and I came here to hate on you
yes but I saw I actually like video now
it doesn't happen all the time but I
find it really funny when someone comes
here because they heard they want to be
angry speaking about us and then was
like you know what you guys are actually
different than I expected gets people
here my thing's always just time because
like I don't know if the people that are
editing those videos realize that
they're going to die CU everyone dies or
not but like whenever I'm editing I'm
always like aware that I've spent an
hour shaping something and like if I'm
shaping something just to on
something that means I have to love it
at least somewhat of course it's always
so flattering and someone like edits me
so I really please whoever you are
please please please I want the Marvel
sequel because your Captain Marvel
coverage of me was amazing I watch it
like whenever I'm sad uh you can ask my
girlfriend I literally watched it and
she was filming me laughing with Glee
about like the edit and the choices so
give me another dread Dre our dread
reaction is absolutely one of my
favorites dude that was such a good day
a th% like what and we had a great run
between and and uh I think dread Robocop
and funny enough the movie missing are
have been my favorite have been my
favorite reactions well you and I did
dread RoboCop right into equalizer and
like that was a run man equalizer is
pretty great yeah I mean there's a lot
of great like there's been some
reactions we've done where like I man I
did not like that movie yeah but overall
we've had some good picks yeah overall I
think it's been great damn we are behind
yet again uh let me see here oh yeah
lowski th% I know we talked about in the
beginning of the stream maybe you're
just hopping in now but way more excited
for eeko now more than ever um
th% and I'm very very much I like den of
nerds I do I know I've gotten crap for
liking den of nerds but I like den of
nerds yeah I nothing den of nerds I know
has been gotten some and he's
gotten called out by James gun for some
stuff but he owns up to stuff a lot of
the time and and you know I I also think
that in the day and age where you get
like a lot of scoopers or people who
theorize I think he's actually pretty
good at that stuff and uh yeah I like
him yeah I've shared his stuff because
I've I've always liked his
accountability I want to say I think
this is really important especially with
what I'm seeing going on in the chat
right now it is really important to be
able to have a conversation like it's it
sounds odd and simple to say something
like that it's really important you know
I have I have just just last week now
I'll level with you guys I identify as a
liberal I don't want to get political
here I do I identify as a liberal it
doesn't mean I can't talk with someone
who's Republican two of the closest
people in my life who we Avo like
they're neighbors of mine and I they are
the sweetest you've met them they're two
the sweetest human beings you will ever
meet and I go out of my way to talk to
them if they're outside like when I
leave here I'm like I got super super
sweet guys
and I I love them and and there's been a
long
time there's been there's been a very
very long time I wonder what that too I
knew they were we just avoided talking
about politics and then uh the last
couple times we hung out we've talked
significantly about politics and we
clearly have extremely different point
of views on a lot of things what's going
on currently in the world uh certain
situations that you know what not
there's a lot of things that but at the
end of the day I'm like I still see them
and I hug every time and I I love to
chat with them and we joke about our
differences yeah you know even I am not
religious I am not a religious human
being yeah and yet I could still watch
something that was critically panned
like Father stew sure and go I found
that very moving yeah but I'm not going
to be but I'm not you know and I shot
passion twice in theaters and you know
where I stand in religion like it's
still a moving story so what I'm saying
is is that we're dealing we're fandom
we're dealing with geekdom stuff
you know we're dealing with fictional
storytelling and while business is a big
part of it at at the and I know how
important these I just did a video about
like why Matthew Perry's performance uh
changed my life and I really meant it
absolutely I'm saying though that in a
day and age with the internet where it's
just people just spew vitrio and bio
left and right I think it is important
to have a conversation and and to be
able to just talk about another side
without it being
just trying to like kill each other yeah
I mean we don't survive if that's the
case a lot of people like say that I
cause tribalism and I cause like hate
it's just like I I'm I I identify as
left leaning but I have strong negative
feelings towards the far left and the
far right it's just the far right in my
opinion has things that harm certain
people more directly and the farle has
things that harm people very directly
but it's it's so violent the far ends of
either Spectrum so I do think that like
tribalism is a problem and I do think
that I at times fall into causing more
of it because I'm very very opinionated
but that's what I do for a living as I
give my opinion I will always try to
listen but there is a threshold if you
say enough things that I patently
disagree with I'm not going to value
your opinion about anything like if I
see that you are overtly racist whether
it's subconsciously or consciously and
that it can happen where you're
subconsciously misogynistic where you're
subconsciously big because you're raised
a certain way but if I hear enough out
of you that I think you diametrically
oppose my worldview there is a time that
I stop listening or caring about your
opinion and that can cause tribalism but
there's so many hours in the day there's
only so many days in your life and
there's only so much bandwidth you have
to tolerate hate and violence so I do
think we should actively listen to
people I do think we should actively try
to find a middle ground but I also think
that some people try to be far gone some
people try to be stuck in their ways and
and it's really hard when you're dealing
with things that are important to a lot
of people like how how Greg feels about
Matthew Perry how I feel about comic
books and movies how how like to me this
is the closest thing I'll ever identify
with as religion to me like the Bible
and comic books are the same thing
they're both fictional stories with a
moral compass I want people to read
comic books to be driven to be better
people some people want to be reading
the Bible to be driven to be better
people to me there is absolutely no
difference and just like with the Bible
it causes a lot of fighting as long as
you're not reading your scripture and it
causing you to be violent we're cool but
the second you decide to make your love
of something mean someone else's love of
something is lesser or your love of
something causing you to hate someone
else because they don't follow that same
book then we got a problem so as long as
you're about loving stuff loving people
seeing people as equal seeing people as
wanting to succeed and thriving in
positivity we're cool no matter what
side of political Spectrum you're on but
the second you got a problem with
someone because you're brainwashed into
thinking they're blank we we're gonna
catch hands verbally or physically so I
just like love people it's that simple
and the internet is so full of hate I'm
more full of hate and it's hard for me
so uh much love to everyone that's been
cool and much you to the Skyler
guy he's still going till Skyler attacks
me I'm okay with
it that's the way I
roll oh wait I had this all set up wrong
there we go but thank you guys I had a
that because I know having a Nuance
conversation via with people on a chat
and the internet is very is almost
impossible it's much easier for me to
say like oh yeah my neighbors who I can
sit down with for an hour and talk or
I'll say it right now or even Tyro
Magnus who I have had very big
disagreements conversations on but it
never got ugly when talking with him
about some stuff we disagreed on like
being able to just have a conversation
in persons is obviously exceptionally
different than this you know yeah uh Dan
v900 uh are thank you so much again are
there plans to ever do more DC animated
film reactions see if when you're
editing a video you don't take like top
this move
on but 900 are there plans to ever do
more DC animated film reactions or were
the views to low I must once again
recommend Justice Le the New Frontier as
a great speech about uniting the matter
the side as Heroes yeah you see some
people don't understand uh and I'll take
my moment to explain this is that yeah
the the film reactions on those really
started to go down we weren't breaking
even like if I'm not editing we have the
prepper people editing and then usually
it's myself or John who are working on
the the re-edit for for something like
that right um and the thing about it was
we just were not even breaking even uh
on it anymore and we we had it was like
put a lot of time here like it is a lot
of I'm glad I could employ Ki for that
and I'm glad the prepper people could be
employed but I'm we're like there's no
they're not making any we're in the
negatives now so this doesn't make any
sense anymore to to do it so we did we
and I kept trying we tried it out for a
while longer even though even though
it's was like oh yeah past the point we
would have usually St because people are
passionate it's not panic attack where
you're like one video whatever you know
but then when you're like it's happening
consistently you know and I think you
guys did pass the point of the DC
animated movies where the interest
started going down and we tried we new
ones old ones I don't think it was
anything to do with Coy and John I I
think it was just with the with the
movies became uh or what was left but
you never know I mean they might if they
start to pick up it can open the door
for conv and maybe like when Superman's
coming out we can throw on a super
something like you know what I mean if
if something but as of now uh we're
doing as much like action movie stuff
and stuff that's moving and grooving
yeah yeah because it's always about the
here is always about the middle ground
of of what will the audience be
interested in of course I think it's a
lie that any YouTuber says that they
don't care about views of course you
care about when it's your livelihood you
care about views at the same like at the
same time I I'm I'm also um
to be frank with you guys is like I also
really care
about liking what we do at the same time
that sounds weird there are some things
that we were like I wasn't like there's
a time we were doing try not to laughs
and they were like easy ass views but I
didn't like doing them and so I stopped
doing them it got to a point where I was
like I don't really enjoy this I don't
really feel like there's anything
fulfilling we're doing about a try not
to laugh CH like maybe once in a life
once in a Li uh once in a blue moon but
more often than not I was like doing
this consistently just I don't know I'm
not a really big fan of it and I think
that's important because it's
inauthentic to the rest of the stuff
that you like on the channel because
then you're if you're if you're trying
to like stuff you don't like yeah and
like very recently I turn down there
some sometimes you get these brand deals
which I really appreciate getting
because it allows me to keep paying the
other people who come on here or help
out with the channel and the there was
something that happened very recent
where sometimes with a certain brand
deal you got to get a certain view count
required and you got to like tell them
what it is and I realized like kind of
just going through averages on views I
was like I could agree to this and I
could just make a couple more videos and
I had to tell them that this is going to
make me not like doing the channel like
sure I can get more money from this
brand by agreeing to this but I'd rather
take less if that means I can still
enjoy making the videos we make right so
it always has to be in the middle here
like will it get the will it get some
views of course that matters any
YouTuber who tells you that
maybe there are those who who really
don't give a I'm not going to say
there aren't and sometimes I do a video
once in a while actually yeah i' say I'd
say every once like saw I was like I
just enjoyed watching that just let him
do it yeah they're not really getting
views but it's fun to watch let him do
it uh but the and then sometimes you're
just like I got to keep people employed
so just let them let them do it yeah
just it but um a lot of times it is
it is about meeting the middle ground of
like what will'll get enough views and
then also will we enjoy
will we are we interested in doing it
that's a very that's a very important
factor that's also part of the brand is
what we're putting out like what we want
to be you know getting the word out
about so I think that's important too
we'll let that show
um here we go thank you fly swada that's
the problem with these sh HIDs so many
people came at me like I just I won't
listen to people if they don't agree
with me I literally went on a like a
longer than I wanted to rant about
there's a threshold but I want to listen
to people again I just I feel like
education and therapy are utilized in
this country we have not talked yet
about um gen V we have to talk about oh
yes Jaden Stevens hey Greg and Koy love
the channel thank you for the Super Chat
I'm really enjoy low season 2 but I do
find some fults with the way Sylvia
isn't really taking accountability
agreed um I that was one of the first
things I was saying yeah he's been
saying that since two three like from
the beginning ever since the McDonald's
episode the one I was like no
accountability yeah and it hasn't
changed number episode 5 like I we're
about to end the show it loses the gray
of the conversation it really does it it
loses the impact of the gray of the
finale of season one because that was
nuanced as book yeah it and and I think
one thing I often credit Loki with is
how nuanced it is yeah and to me some of
the Nuance does get lost with Sylvie
yeah it's if anything at anyone's that
feel like I I see a lot of the intent
with Sylvie but I think a lot of it is
thinly written I agree and that is one
of the parts of that is like and it's so
close to being like we've given like
three notes in our some of our reviews
where we're like if they just did this
and if we're thinking of it and we're in
around one of the writers room of the
conversation like I you know I mean they
go through multiple drafts they like
dive into it so if we're coming up with
stuff round one it would be nice yeah
Nuance is the key word nuance is gold
and that's what I think that the good
MCU properties TV or film have had I
think Guardians of the Galaxy 3 did well
because there was Nuance uh I think you
know Loki does well because there's
Nuance there is some poorly written
Marvel um I and and this maybe this will
help the people that are so angry at me
in the chat understand I don't love the
first Captain Marvel movie I don't think
it is very nuanced I think the twist is
very um uh pandering and uh really
really like in your face from the
beginning it's not a good twist it's
very mustache twirling um I don't think
that first Captain Marvel earned its
billion dollars from the movie I think
it was in between um you know two
Avengers films and I think it got a lot
of love for a lot of things that it
didn't quite deserve that being said
nothing I have against the first Captain
Marvel movie has anything to do with um
you know Bri Larson has anything to do
with uh the fact that it's a a female
superhero my issue is people that have
those issues with the movie versus the
issues that I think have some Nuance to
them I'm excited for the Marvels because
I'm a big NE aasta fan I'm excited for
the Marvels because I think Brie Larson
has within her the ability to play the
Captain Marvel that I feel like she can
be I don't feel like Brie Larson played
Carol Danvers in the first movie to me
how I interpret the character so I'm
excited for the Marvels if I don't like
it it'll have unless something happens
in the movie that I haven't seen
anything to do with those things that
bother me about those type of YouTube
channels so that's I think the
difference in what I perceive uh certain
elements of the internet versus my take
on liking or disliking a movie Captain
Marvel one is in my bottom five Marvel
films hard
stop yeah when koi starts talking I
start refreshing here to help
here to help him now he's the guy in the
chair um but yeah it's a Nuance is
important all right now we got to start
getting better at quality efficient
every this is why we haven't streamed in
a long time this is what happen this is
what happens I talking we end up talking
for way too long antagonized the chat
more than normal which I apologize for
oh man you've become a polarizing figure
great time to launch your new show yeah
hey they'll get comments they'll be
yelling at me it'll drive things
up going to be like Aman volani is going
to want to come on the channel be like I
didn't like what you had to say about
nerd
rtic man there's a clip
out I actually agree with everything
iric hey and maybe she does maybe he's
great how ironic would that be dude the
whole Marvel cast is like actually huge
fans got a lot Ki should really not just
look at his thumbnails Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe there's Nuance
there there might be you know you never
know sometimes people just do to
you he's the co-host of this episode
right once in a while I I'll see I mean
I like I've given a lot of the CH
channels a peak of of things that I I
always give a channel an actual shot I
think it's important for me personally
like I I I respect if you're like you
see you see the conversation it a lot of
people can look at the conversation it
ignites yeah you know and then and then
you could kind of see the effect that
said person public figure whatever it is
might have on people you know so if you
don't want to watch I get it but you
know I'm I'm like a Rogan fan like I
like joean I was watching Joe Rogan and
Russell br cuz I I like those were two
of my guys for years and as I was
watching it the like all the assault
allegations for Russell Brand were
happening like live like literally I was
watching that episode and then Twitter
was blowing up and he was trending and I
was like I keep trying to understand and
it was so like a great microcosm of me
just like trying to reach across the
aisle um I still love what Rogan
attempts to do with having like all
voices on a channel it's just very funny
that like every time I try to do what
you're describing I get like a swift
kick uh let's see here let's see here
okay benen benen hey Ben 10 um hey Yuri
hope you're
well half hey why is American box office
so important uh I don't see your other
half and two when are you judging a film
success honestly I'm not your go-to guy
to give a clear answer of why I mean
American box maybe because that's where
Cinema became Cinema I I don't that's
true actually I feel like Cinema
like came from Germany or something I
remember that are like America versus
other box office or why to Americans is
box office so important uh I think why
is American box office so important I
mean it's it is the Hub of where most
movies make their I think Hollywood yeah
I think like Hollywood films the box
office is important to Hollywood to know
like what we're doing for the audience
that starts here I think you know
obviously Bollywood has a huge huge
Market I didn't know they played films
like 18 hours a day yeah I know they
like start like 6:00 a.m. and go to like
I believe bollywood's bigger than
American but I don't know something
about the American dollar which keeps
going value which is yeah I I personally
can only give a theory I'm not I'm not
by no means an expert who could be but I
think box office is just important
because the business side of show
business so if the question is like box
office in general I think it's just like
if you're going to run a business it has
to stay afloat uh I do worry that the uh
the Hollywood accounting is a very big
issue like we just had an article come
out about you know another movie that
made $500 million but only profited 55
so the people with backend points got
like seven cents there are issues there
but I mean box office it's kind of like
we were saying with clicks on YouTube
you you have to in a business stay
afloat to keep making things so it it
sucks that art has to be so commodified
but in the case of movies it is a
commodified art oh yeah no Matt Colton I
agree I I mean I watch Dam roll every
week I think it's it's it's crazy like
deal is one of those people who I'm um
used to have it with Koy now I'm used to
yeah where I would get around have see
Dan I've literally had like one-on-one
movie fights with Dan you know i' like
I've had to my experence
with like doing stuff on camera with Dan
talked to him plenty times off camera
but I watch him so much that whenever I
see him like
Dan I'm I'm not used to you I forget
that like you'll see me and know who I
am and I forget that it was wicked funny
when I shaved my head Greg had this like
Double Take of like it's COI from the
internet it was so funny that I saw his
brain go to like when he didn't know me
like I was in the room as old 2018 me is
the streamlabs one wrong
uh I don't know that's a great question
with koi jandro oh um let me try it out
I think it's right let me I mean have we
gotten oh we haven't gotten any yeah we
have is this streamlabs yeah which one
did we geter we read yeah but that's
October 24th oh did I read an old one
yeah oh my God I read an old ass one I
think the stream La is broken I read an
old ass one cuz it's currently November
my bad that was a week ago oh wait got
one from Michael Ma so he got through
okay I don't understand that's weird all
right try it again check the
tapes I don't know all right I
don't know guys I'm literally tight
copying and pasting it but I appreciate
you trying nice to know you tried uh no
you guys you guys have been so
generous today thank you thank you and
let's see here let me try it again all
right it's the same link the same
link I don't know I don't know I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what's happening I do miss movie fights
yeah me too man that show was great I'm
doing a uh I got got to talk to you
after there's a there's a movie fighti
is thing coming up oh
nice beating up some homeless people on
the street later yeah I got to talk to
you about it with my
point you just have to listen to my
point of view Pingus is saying thank you
Pingus for the Super Chat hey guys I
hope your day is hold on let me pull up
uh where' it go hold on Coy it's right
here all right I was wondering keep here
I was wonder if there will be more dcma
reaction I just talked about that also
be watching the aot finale thanks Greg
I'll probably be cover it on patreon
because the pressure to cover that on
YouTube is tough uh only because I I
respect other reaction channels who know
how to get around the copyrights or
strikes on anime I have not and it
created too many panic attacks for it
yeah and I frankly just don't want to
put myself through it to be totally
honest with you uh the the other side of
it is that
um uh I need to do like a I'll feel like
I'm going to rush to that I I need it
even though I read Attack on Titan other
than the last issue because didn't want
it spoiled for me cuz anime and manga
tend to be pretty Sim it's okay so it
would be a parall it would be like yeah
even reading the manga than watching
like there's slight differences very
slight but for the most part it you're
pretty much watching the show versus
what's cool about reading a manga in an
anime that I think in terms of medium
comparisons is other than putting a
voice and motion to it is manga often in
black and white oh and then anime they
color it in so you get a different
experience that is cool um so I read the
Manga for other than the very last
issues but at the same time it's been a
long time yeah so I'm like I need to do
like a big refresher that's big though
on patreon people are way more forgiving
when I don't remember something it's the
final thing because there are people
that are like I already know Greg I like
him first like how do you know I'm like
sorry man it's been a long
time um Xavier Johnson saying uh love
you all thank you for the super chat
buddy completely agree with you koi too
hate is so ubiquitous nowadays opinions
on on quality versus quantity and tvma
MCU keep it up love your content guys
well appreciate it man thank you uh
quality versus quantity and tvma MCU um
I think that quality is much more
important than quantity but I think that
there's this concept of um there's this
Con concept of infinite growth uh that I
think really started with the internet
so when you've got like uh Uber and Lyft
when they started they were subsidized
companies like venture capitalist
subsidized these big companies so while
they were getting infinite growth it
made sense for the VCS to kind of
monitor those things but there was that
time about a year ago when the the
numbers spiked and how much it cost to
take an Uber lift and that's because
people pulled out because they weren't
growing infinitely anymore uh same
happens with social media uh like
threads was growing infinitely because
people didn't want to be on Twitter but
then it plummeted because it couldn't
keep up infinite growth and then it lost
traction and now it's like infinitely
small but I think there's an issue with
with our perception of capitalism and
money is if something's not growing it's
not doing well and I think that with
quality you need the thing to grow in
quality in order to to sustain it so a
universe like the MCU needs to stay at a
quality level but people that make money
people that are the studio heads because
it show business want quantity and I
think you sacrifice quality with
quantity because it just unsustainable
you don't have enough visual effects
artists enough editors enough writers
all those things so I think that there
needs to be both and I think that
sometimes you have to mitigate some loss
with either one or the other but if you
lose both quality and quantity that's
when you start to plummet so I don't
know how to solve that for the MCU
because I'm not a producer but I do
think what they're doing with the ma and
what they're doing with uh kind of
slowing down on shows will help us
bounce back to that I hope that answers
your question
yeah and thank you uh I I think um I
think we we we try to have uh more
positivity than negativity here I I just
think it is a vulnerability I think
loving stuff is harder to do publicly
because when you love something and
someone else says they hate it it feels
like they're saying they hate you
whereas when you say I hate something
and someone else says they hate it it
feels like you're part of a club so I
think that just inherently human beings
want to feel welcome and they want to
there's literally chemical things in our
brain that go off when you feel like
your social status raises or when you
feel like you find people like you I
think it's a lot harder to feel like
people feel like you with love because
it's so much more vulnerable and it's so
much harder to get out there and that's
why a lot of people hate me and
it's exhausting but I would much rather
Love Stuff uh overall I also think it's
easier to hate people than to hate
art uh whatever you said I agree uh
Christi
pronounceable like the stream everyone
it helps out the guys helps out the guys
we need the help thank
you leave a like on this stream that's
you can that mean that it helps with the
playback Brandon
Jed all right Spaceman I see your
comment coming in I'm going to use that
as an as a weird opportunity to segue to
some gen B thoughts oh I like it
thank you all you do Greg and coy coy
can you give Conor rex or Dr Doom
stories oh I mean definitely Secret Wars
the newest one Fantastic Four issue
number
49 uh the the rise of Silver
Surfer Jessica definitely that one yeah
go back to watch the movie Dr Doom 100%
uh I would say the new Secret Wars is
some of the best Doom I've ever read um
there was a Dr Doom solo title about two
years ago that I think is a very
approachable book the problem with Dr
Doom is a lot of stuff is very uh it's
like issue 17 like there's just like
these great little one-offs in books and
then you'd have to read a lot to really
you know get all that um so I would say
the Dr Doom solo book from a couple
years back I think it was like 2020 or
2021 uh I would say secret Wars the
newest one that came out in 2015 uh I
would also recommend checking out
uh do those two and then when the movie
is getting closer I'll do like a more
individual issues one but those two are
are very approachable very true very
good call Spaceman
Spaceman guys we're gonna talk about
genv I'm gonna use this as an
opportunity for some reason to segue
into
it just want you to know thank you SPAC
man for a very generous Super
Chat just want you and the r team to
know how much the content means to your
fans does
it we know how much work goes into these
videos the first thing we do after an
episode airs is refresh your page a
seriously thank you both uh yeah I I do
I see that there are we do have a a core
of people for sure usually they're the
ones who show up in the live streams too
so I appre we we really do appreciate
the core it's something that uh I'm
still not quite used to
because I like we are just I think on
the internet anyone I don't care how big
you get on the internet to act like
you're some like important celebrity is
the most annoying thing in the
world to me you know like when people
get like shy to approach me like why
like there's no reason to unless I'm
peeing but then then be shy I I get it I
I I I get shy around other people uh for
sure like just talking about Dad Merl I
was all like oh yeah that's right beat
yourself uh but um it is it is such a
thing of of like we we're here just
being ourselves you know yeah and and I
I I really love that and I thank
everyone for being here and with us
being ourselves I'm going to awkwardly
transition into gen V speaking of being
ourselves I I know there will be a
comment on the playback we like when do
they talk about geny it's and it's at
the hour and a half minute yeah that's
what they wanted that's what they wanted
us to talk about yeah we are nowhere
near a celebrity we're we're like I I
think like internet celebrity is when
you're like honestly when you're when
you're like Sniper Wolf subscribers
Sniper Wolf oh my God he doesn't know
about Sniper Wolf what sniper is that
like when you do I explain the sniper
SSS Sniper Wolf situation ncoy do you
know anything about this is it a
username it's oh this is great oh my God
you don't know about sniper you said USS
sniper was it a boat this is
hilarious oh dude you don't know
anything about her should we play oh
it's her
okay I'm so what teach me I don't like
internet culture it's a gross
place has so many followers or like
Markiplier like that's like I know him
that's like internet that's like a
internet celebrity he had a movie made
out of his stuff yeah like that's like a
real I'm not going to take this I
learned who the be look the sniper
later all right the Beast is someone I
know of but there are people you meet
like in in these influencer circles
where you can see the ego and I'm I I
don't I generally don't like going to
those people know that about me I often
say it when I'm there like I don't
really want to be here so yeah um I just
I don't like the internet a lot I can't
believe you don't know it's gross all
the internet does is SP she's been the
topic of conversation for such a long
time you might be winning back to People
by not knowing who she is anyway gen V
COI is a boomer confirmed yep I just I
would rather be a boomer than no
geny so she she docked a guy named Jack
films You Know Jack films is Jack
films like JX films it's just been so
huge at like so so funny you
like don't like legally even legal eagle
you legal Al the real lawyer reacts guy
like a PR
firm you're speaking Latin like I feel
like you're reading a mat Li you're like
legal eagle Jack films m is like Sniper
Wolf is like a boat like USS Sniper Wolf
oh Jesus Christ I don't know I'm like
where do I begin to open up this yeah
like what is this journey there's three
very major players with silly
names okay all right I'll try to explain
it I was going to talk about I love that
we're still delaying gen V I was going
to try to talk about gen V
but I'll try to explain this okay all
right all right all right all right all
right here it is all right here it is so
Sniper Wolf is like one of the biggest
YouTubers ever okay she's got like I
don't know 40 30 million subscribers
she's huge what she mainly does is these
uh reactions to a compilation of Tik Tok
videos okay and um it's one of the
things that just contributes to
reactions getting a bad name first like
frankly and because she doesn't really
add much commentary she doesn't do
anything transformative she doesn't even
credit the creators of the Tik toks not
like she drives traic there this other
YouTuber who's never really liked
reaction videos um Jack Jack's films
okay and he started up his own channel
called J Jack's films to make fun of s
Sniper Wolf and the whole thing has been
going on for months which is just
basically a massive um critique of her
Channel like it's he's actually making
real content though it's not just about
her channel it's not just spoof like
he's making a real concept he's doing it
for a few months she's obviously been
getting really upset about it getting
really livid and she did something that
was quite heinous uh she went to his
house whoa like real life yeah on her
Instagram story with five million people
she took a Instagram she took photo of
his house and and something along the
lines of like come outside and let's
talk like adults basically baiting him
but she showed everyone where he lived
in real life yeah so she doxed him and
so whatever people have to say about
like the level of criticism Jack films
dealt her way there's real life and
there's the internet I'm like that one's
a criticism and sure like maybe it was
excessive but you still you're putting
someone's life in danger at that point
yeah that's terrify and that's a
completely different situation there's a
literal Line in the Sand and it's your
router yeah and and he uh and so he
obviously was not happy about it did a
video about it sniper wolv was beginning
attack like crazy YouTube was silent
because YouTube plays favoritism people
have gotten literally their accounts
removed off YouTube for joking about
doxing and then they eventually were
like we're going to temporarily suspend
her monetization she didn't get arrested
she got temporarily demonetized yeah
temporarily demonetized and they also
made a comment on it that was like it's
about both like we don't want to see
this kind of behavior on both sides as
if Jax films did something wrong when
I'm like he didn't for living somewhere
yeah uh yeah the way YouTube handled it
was cowardice and wow and and they
clearly just didn't want to lose their
moneymaking machine of Sniper Wolf who
does make lazy reaction video content
literally it's it is like when we do
like a movie reaction or show it's like
that that takes a lot of time to put
that together yeah you know um and then
hers is is like kind of like a
predictable thing you know what and
there's not really any afterthoughts
that go into it's just the three minutes
it's a real commentary yeah yeah stretch
out a minut so it's real bad situation
and and uh yeah know she's been making
the rounds she had to turn off her
comments she if she's figured out a way
to get around the monetization CU she
has a second Channel where she's been
uploading content to that is so yeah
that's like and legal eagle is her
lawyer no legal eagle that's the best
comment legal eagle is a huge YouTube
channel I'm wondering how he relates or
she relates it's like lawyer reacts too
and he does breakdowns of it and he
broke down the whole situation on the
wow yeah yeah legal eal is her
lawyer I was I was waiting for the third
name to come in I was so funny I learned
a lot uh yeah so but I just got a video
in IRL I got to experience it legal
eagle
lawyer Dan v900 holy thank you so
much I'm incredibly excited for Kingdom
of the planet the Apes the rider Z so
you wouldn't get that
in we still we will get to chv we will
this is like Matt Damon wanting to get
an interview on Kimmel we will get to
Chen apologies to Andor
oh legal legalist or lawyer it's just so
funny if you know who legal legalist
like legals or law it sounds like a
lawyer that would defend me somewhat I'm
incredibly
excited for Kingdom of the pl of the
Apes the writers on board are great with
two from Rise of Dawn and West ball
directing the trailer was awesome the
recent should get more credit I agree
Dan b900 I think they kept it like as
simple to as Grant I think the t's
needed to like have a bit more of an
impact
to show what's going to be different or
unique or something special it doesn't
it doesn't really do anything other than
like like we're making another planet of
the Earth movie it doesn't really do
anything that special and and I think
that's that's the mark that you need to
hit like if you watch I remember the
Dawn of the Planet of the Apes trailer
that's how impactful that was oh it's
still one of the great the closeup on
Caesar's face the slow pan out and then
he puts his hand up and he's got all the
people behind him and it's just tone
atmosphere
ickiness dread that's all it is and
you're just like this movie's going to
be the I can't wait to see this
yeah and like that movie to this day is
one of those like maybe the great
Trilogy that no one talks about in the
great Trilogy conversations like I feel
like people are finally talking about
before they're F he finally saw How to
Train Your Dragon uh reaction on this
channel but like those are known I feel
like the the the Apes trilogy because it
was a sequel to a' 70s movie nobody like
gives it that do but I think that's one
of the great franchises those Apes
movies are incredible yeah so yeah the
trailer is fantastic I'm very much
looking forward to it and Andy Circus
deserves many and Oscar Apes on horses
and guns yeah uh let's see here d drv d
I nailed it barard was I nailed it yep
nailed it you don't need to correct me
wants not to pronounce his name it's drv
barash hey y'all I've been a fan since
2014 just want to know if you guys are
still friends with Tyro Magnus I haven't
talked to him in quite a long
time um but whenever we do talk we get
along I didn't know who he was to this
channel it's been a long time since we
but last time he was out here we did uh
meet up and like I said we don't see eye
to eye on a lot but I can still have a
conversation with them and I think it's
really important not just to be able to
to have a conver there is a word called
bipartisanship which doesn't exactly
mean what I'm talking about but kind of
kind of means it like we should be able
to have a discussion when they do review
genv the kids will be out of college and
in the
seven you do know when you when you
can't have a conversation oh yeah there
are people it's not about trying to
change someone's mind it is like some
people think it's about debate and win
and a lot times it is just about like
well dialogue is important to like
understand other worldviews in general
even if you're not going to change your
mind it's good to understand other
people's
perspective don't worry Co we'll talk
about jmv I'm just you know I'm letting
the letting the chat know I'm gonna make
chapters on this video it's going to be
live stream and then one chapter
just entire live stream J at the two
hour mark J will appear I'll do
it man I'm I'm wild like that man I'll
do it man do it
do don't stop don't stop him don't think
he won't as long as we keep people in
the chat talking about it it'll
encourage us to do it Jeff uh Christian
unpronouncable thank you Christian
Christian do you think Loki and Kevin
from shehulk will ever meet no no I
think Kevin's just a She-Hulk show uh
thing I don't think we'll see uh more
Kevin personally I think it's a funny
bit I think it's a a great meta
commentary but uh I don't think we'll
see Kevin outside of She-Hulk I think it
would be so cool if we did though yeah
travels to a universe I feel like we're
more likely to see Kevin in like an
across the SP uh into the spiderverse
joke we are see that's great I like that
I think also Kevin could appear in like
um secret Wars like when they do all the
multiversal stuff I think there might be
like a flash but that's the only like
She-Hulk allows for meta commentary that
only Secret Wars might because I think
there's going to be a lot of metanis in
there but I I definitely don't see him
popping up in like
Loki uh let's see here Jeff
Carroll interesting question Jeff what's
the coolest name ever why is it London
Thor what what is the coolest name ever
I feel like I think Ashton's a cool name
because they always sound like
douchebags but you always want them to
like you oh I like that I'm tiberious
why you want you want the pro for I call
everyone tiberious I call my cat my
cat's middle name is tiberious cu I love
that name I don't know tiberious is so
cool James tiberious cat yeah what
nonous MCU project do each of you want
to be announced next and why oh my god
dude I I would
love I would love
a which X-Men property should get
announc COI are you ready for a lot of
people to be mad at me and think I'm
just saying it because it's woke Rogue
storm it's the most cinematic backstory
it's the most obvious for a big scale
movie it's a character that leads the
X-Men and has an actual like oomph
before the X-Men it's a character that's
never gotten her due because she gets
like lines like what happens to a toad
get truck by lightning it's a character
that hasn't really been like utilized in
any Medium as strongly as she could be
and it's a character that has a built-in
audience of people that been waiting for
all those things I think storm is the is
the character uh deserves a movie well
before the X-Men movie like I I think
storm by by a lot question for the chat
putting it in here which X-Men character
should get their uh solo debut or
movie putting it in here chat putting in
here and then not by actual assessment
but just by thinking of quickly reading
names I'm going
to I'm going to try to assess which one
Jubilee is not a bad pick that's fun
Forge is great too I love love Forge uh
NC is great pull uh also I actually know
London Thor U she was like an acting
school with me back when I was an actor
boy London's the best that's why I
freaked out when she was on the show
because I was like my worlds are
colliding superhero stuff in London damn
Storm's getting a lot of love
Yeah
Cyclops I've never understood the Sentry
love but I'm glad people love him it's
just not a character i' ever connected
with I think Gambit is ODed I think
Gambit Ed I think storms Ed more but I
think gambits
owed I think morph they should do morph
oh yeah morph origin story for sure
morph and and Mystique a lot of kitty
Prides or three Kitty Prides in a row
which I I support I'm the Juggernaut
solo Juggernaut movie angel angel
Rogue storm storm would be great I think
storm would be a great pick it's just
it's so Roland emiy you know like the
disaster movie and like a girl that's
trying to survive in a in a climate that
doesn't like help mut lost me at
Rollo no but that that style of film
theong he's not directing it he's not
directing it but like that style of
movie he likes his big
storms picture twister but with a
someone wielding them just picking a
great character tster noted by ring em
wonderful pitch
and but that style of film making that
big big Global catastrophe he's not
directing it you can see the twister in
the storms with the stor it's so great I
want
it she should just be fighting like
thugs on the
street $20 million budget small gritty
store movie also Mohawk
mandatory oh yeah it's good man crash
illustration thank you so much my friend
hey guys apparently the Variety article
has been debunked I keep hearing that
but how how has the Variety article been
debunked the writer actually can someone
tell me how it's been debunked I'm not
saying you're wrong I'm asking what is
debunked about it I want you guys do me
a favor I want you to leave this when
we're done I want you to go over to the
big thing Christian's Channel and you
write that in that chat all those people
are so mad at me for thinking it was a
Fluff piece I I I'm very curious as to
how it's debunked because I saw one
thing on Twitter of some writer who did
work on blade and said that any of the
drafts he was involved in were none of
these drafts when I'm like I don't know
these big scripts go through like 20
drafts it also feels like everything
mentioned in that article is exactly the
antagonistic thing that someone that
wants to complain about bra would say
like the quotes are literally like I
don't know blade was the fourth lead
after a woman like it feels like someone
wrote it to be like I want them to be
mad yeah I just don't know how it's I I
would like to know what is actually
debunked yeah I'm curious too yeah or is
it an opinion of what's the bun Connor
Davis do we think Loki is going to be
part of Secret
Wars yes but not in a direct way I think
he's going to be op I think he's going
to play a part but I don't think he's
going to be like on the ground level
don't worry guys we're going to talk
about J V in a
second Diego G
thank you
Diego okay I'm seeing a comment coming
in so I was just reading the top one I
was like he's paused very dramatically
Diego
Gava just got here I don't know what
we're talking about but I've been W to
ask for some time any thoughts on TES
possibly playing dazzler in Deadpool 3 I
don't know if they should do it I mean
I'd be down for anything with Taylor
Swift I love I don't know if they should
do it why would it they it's perfect I
mean it would make money it would make
money she's actually a perfect cast
decision for could be an original song
variety would let her know that she's on
the red carpet at the premiere before
the movie even airs no but I think she
could make an original song would show
up oh 100% dude change the GDP of a
country she's got like so much clout she
she helped register for voting like
she's a bad she deserved it I am totally
and like her and Ryan are real life
friends I get crap for liking her he had
her cats on his shirt in the first film
it ties into Canon it's meta it would
actually help the budget all of it
there's layers to it it's not quite as
meta as some of the jokes that are gonna
be in the film but her being friends
with Ryan and the cats and the the box
office impact 100% Swifty bring it in
yeah th% man I'd be down and she's
actually good casting like she it's not
like just fluff she can sing and be
dazzler bring
it Melvin berus I want to read this I've
seen a couple Vios thank you Melvin
bangas sorry benas my God I se a couple
videos saying that the writing article
is just a hitpiece well yeah yeah it was
written by Tiana SEO who also did the
hit piece against Ray Fischer when he
came out against
Weeden I can understand feeling like The
credibility can be tarnished because of
a prior piece that was written but does
that exactly debunk what was stated I
think he wrote this before you asked for
a debunking you know yeah yeah know I
get it but I but I I am questioning what
the debunk yeah yeah I'm questioning
what the debunk is I uh I've been using
that term on uh this network on new
rockstars on harof channel i' I've
spoken about this article more than I
like to even acknowledge but uh I think
this is a factor I don't think it
completely invalidates the article if
the article I felt like was sound I'm
not going to judge a writer's entire
work off of one article that apparently
you know had had some fluff in it
hopefully she's a better writer than
just like tearing people down I don't
know this writer's work but uh I do
think there is if there's a pattern if
there's smoke there might be fires what
I'm saying uh at the same time I also
think that people want to be angry like
there's a lot of I mean there's the
people that keep popping in the chat
like the world's on fire why are we
talking about nothing one escapism two
pop culture is important to culture
three we're not politically driven as a
channel it'd be weird if we talked about
how the world's actually on fire but I
think that because of the world being on
fire and I think because everyone feels
this anxiety and animosity and tension
there's a lot of people stoking that
fire with like I can't talk about the
real stuff that's happening let me be
mad at this innocuous thing and this
article feels like people trying to put
literal gasoline on an innocuous thing I
my heart breaks for the real world I am
not educated enough on 100% of the
topics to really go into that because I
I talk about this stuff I think this
person is using the world being on fire
using people's animosity in the internet
to cause there to be animosity about
something that doesn't warrant it so
personally this is gross to me
personally I'd love if we weren't this
kind of culture we're not but it sucks
that this is what everyone's talking
about cuz it's exhausting
again yeah
yeah totally koi Greg was
listening use an opportunity to reply to
a text message we just see how yep no my
stocks are doing fine stop a stop a job
I want to really quick I want to read
this streamlabs because someone figured
out how to get into here and it's really
impressive how they figured it out oh
what they do I don't know okay John set
us up for failure
John just Michael Mack Michael
exclusively figured it out how long has
it been since the no way home post
credits isn't that the funniest
thing in the world wouldn't the Symbiote
that was left behind be causing chaos by
now any big love from Scotland PS
Skyler H well Sky Skyler's been yeah
Skyler's been better I feel like
Skyler's been apologizing in some ways
or something I'm not sure I need to
check it out before we hop on the
Skyler turn tentative I'd rather I'd
rather see what he says first um before
we before we go do it on that RAB
seriously uh that's my thing with Marvel
right now is I feel like uh and I I've
said this before but maybe not in this
channel as much I think that the chaos
of Marvel was intentionally meant to be
chaos in the beginning and then there
was a lot of Kickback because it didn't
get to the payoff fast enough because of
the Chek era of making so many
properties uh personally I think it is
very intentionally different multiverses
I think that for example the Spider-Man
universe might not be the same one as
some of the other Marvel properties I
think we might have seen variance in it
be a surprise that they're a variant uh
I don't necessarily know if that's what
they're going to pay off at the end but
I do think the original plan was a big
twist in Kang Dynasty to be that like
this character and this character
weren't actually in the same universe
that's why there's no big impact of
celestials or big impact of the symbiot
I could be wrong I could be being
optimistic but it feels more intentional
than just chaotic in that element there
should be Loki video game it would be
cool if Loki and Doctor Who crossed
over uh yeah I think the no way home
post credit scene I'll just the thing
I'll say is like you know that movie is
great when you don't hear people pissed
off about how that post credit scene
totally sucks uh because Venom Let There
Be Carnage the only thing people were
mainly talking about was the post credit
scene yeah of Venom and Tom Holland
clicking the
ision and then no way home is so good
right and no way home goes I guess there
was no point in all that hype and and
the anger just like dissipated on that
vanished because the movie itself was
enough of a strong conversation that
you're like oh yeah I forgot to even be
mad about that post credit scene going
nowhere you know yeah yeah and that's
the strength of a good movie as a post
credit scene should be like a little bit
accent it shouldn't be the movie Yes the
gamer MJ he figured out had to hack the
streamlabs yeah got one in here oh my
God I think he set us up to talk about
gen v no way thank you we'll keep it
short even though I I know everyone's
been clammering at the bit for Gen V con
first to talk about boy season I just
see it in the chat it's brought up
nonstop I'm sorry for delay I just been
waiting build sizzling you know letting
letting him
marinate
uh he says I love your guys' content I
bought the aoda shirt oh yeah I
love that shirt remember think thinking
that up soda so funny genv is easily one
of the best shows of the year I'm super
excited for the Marvels today I bought
Blue Beetle graduation day nice and plan
to read it but my question is Deadpool
Cameo and Loki finale no not going to
happen at most post credit scene
involving something that would lead to
Deadpool but not an actual physical
Deadpool in my opinion yeah I don't
think there's going to be a Deadpool uh
that would be terrible idea I think I
think it would distract from whatever
impact there is it also would be like
well that movie got delayed like I don't
we don't know when we're getting
Deadpool at this point I think they
should really stop planting seeds that
are not yet sewn like there's a lot to
come uh and because the strike I don't
think they should Lean Forward too much
I think they should show Echo um in it
uh yeah let's talk about gen V really
quick boy season 4 um God you know
there's been so much buildup to us
talking about gen V I don't even know
what to talk about well I mean what did
you guys think of the genv finale did
you watch the genv finale put it in the
chat one through 10 or a through F what
do you want us to talk about regarding
gen the boys let's do that Glenn Howton
I think would fet will in the boys
Universe he's got that smarin he's got
that um Cockiness I think you wait no
I'm thinking of Glenn pal wait which
Glen Pal's also good for the boys
Universe I'm thinking of the It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia Glenn Howton that
that is Glenn Howton okay yeah yeah
that's the right who who's pal Pal's Top
Gun oh Pal's the guy with Sydney sweee
that ROM yeah okay yeah yeah yeah all
right sweet um yes at that that is one
point um J boy seems to have a finale
problem I don'tale I I really thought
this finale was quite strong actually
Glenn howerton's my read and Glenn Pal's
my hell Jordan for what it's worth uh I
thought the finale was strong strong
like we loved how like I thought it
rapidly handled a lot of arcs I thought
it had a beautiful way of delivering on
promises from even episode one I thought
the action was fantastic I compared it
to X-Men comic books as like a blueprint
for the X-Men I personally thought it's
delivered on a lot of really important
delicate subject matter like this show
deals with college age kids cutting uh
Bia body issues like it does a lot of
nuanced which is the theme of this
episode nuanced things really well and
then when it landed it I I was
personally very impressed uh how will
Kate and Sam first show up in season 4 I
don't I feel like they're going to be
beloved do you think there will be a
forgiveness with them I think that we'll
only see the boys perspective on them I
think it'll be very intentionally like
look at these holy new like I think
we'll see them cuz this show is like
from the ground up looking at the boys
right whereas the boys is like from the
ground from the up down like I love that
they're two shows with diametrically
opposed viewpoints where we're kind of
looking at the world of soups from from
different places I think when they join
if you've seen gen V you'll be like whoa
whoa whoa but if you haven't and you
only watch the boys they'll be like look
at these great new characters and I
think that'll be really fun discourse
that'll lead people to genv I wonder
what people are a lot of people seem to
not be big on this finale what what was
it about the finale that you didn't like
guys I would love to know what it was
you didn't like I saw a little bit of
that on Twitter but I I definitely
didn't I just thought that was Twitter
uh Aisha Kenya predictions for the next
season of the boys and how everything
ties in I mean it seems like there'll be
use whatever that thing that was being
developed by the scientist the virus it
seems like butcher is probably going to
want to get his hands on that yeah but
also realized that genocide is perhaps
not the answer and I feel like that will
create an inner conflict amongst the
boys yes like huy especially
Frenchy I imag I think all of them would
probably dis think like butcher might
want to go that path and everyone else
would be like whoa whoa whoa and that'll
cause that tension again between Butcher
and them but that seems so predictable
right show isn't generally predictable
and I I feel like they would know that's
the predictable route they'd expect with
their characters and maybe want to go a
different direction then yeah I think
we'll get some interaction between the
characters but not as strong as like a
meshing of shows I think it'll be very
intentionally like the genv is one show
so season two is gonna come back to them
trapped but I don't think we'll get a
lot of them in the boys so I think the B
ramification will be like the the che of
the virus as well asbe new members of
the seven but we have Victoria Newman
who would probably want to use it as a
way to control and it seems like our our
gen V Cast is caught is caught up in the
in the experimentation room yeah yeah
the people are saying too abrupt um
ending unexpected just didn't like it
lackluster I thought everything kind of
came crumbling like was impressed person
Doan's destroyed right now yeah Russian
lack I thought the Arts were great
interesting I thought I thought Marie's
Arc was solid um I thought Marie getting
that like last moment and then
homelander spoilers I thought Jordan was
a little bit um Jordan was the only one
I think we all were like well it was a
little lck I love Kate's descent I also
and this is going to upset there a big
gray to to everything the the show's
pretty much a commentary on our world
the the boys is more of a commentary on
like uh Financial structures and more
the Amazon side where this feels like
it's you know the more the people in
school but I did like that they had that
moment at the very end of the episode
where if there's a a for lack of a
cleaner term like it it dealt with
school shootings which is something that
Jen Z is dealing with more and more I
thought it handled it really well that
the trauma of that was very much breezed
over on the news and on the day certain
characters came in and escalated the
situation to benefit those characters in
authority and I think that's in my
opinion accurate uh so I thought it was
really really well done I feel like what
happened with Kate and Sam I could
understand why the way they went could
be divisive for people but I I think the
way she was pushed the slingshot effect
for Kate did make sense to me of someone
who was very much traumatized used
abused knows what people think and feel
and knows how humans feel and the humans
that especially took advantage of her
yeah of why she would become ultimately
villainous I do agree that I think
Sam uh being persuaded the way he was
felt like
it makes sense still feels rushed though
ites int I can be like yeah he's
brainwashed because he hasn't had any
comfort and kindness at the same time I
think he's a little uh I think he comes
across I understand he's easily
susceptible to be easily influenced
because he's had a lack of social
interaction and he's been trapped there
for a long time at the same time he does
come across like quite competent at
least in the performance I I also uh
didn't like some of the uh brainwashing
elements not being completely clear if
I'm going to nitpick a thing like I
don't like that like Aryan race Trump
hat guy like apparently can run around
that a dick like I don't think we ever
saw I don't think that ever like that is
an element I didn't love like I would
have liked some like well it was that in
her head was that manipulation did Kate
they make her think that that like
moment but overall I thought it was
really good well I think Kate too I feel
like Kate see the same thing I can
actually understand I feel like the Kate
thing she was off the pills too you know
she's kind of just become fully
unleashed the truth is out this is the
thing that need to be suppressed about
her and all the things about her being
suppressed and maybe I'm just giving the
show too much credit I don't know
because clearly there's a lot of people
feel very strong about it um you know
and and I guess I I I've been here like
no I really get it because she I thought
she felt villainous from episode three
on she's been physically suppressed
emotionally and mentally everything
about her has been suppressed now the
truth is out there and she's no longer
medicated that to me for her and you see
the background she had where even her
family disowned her or at least her F
the everyone else's family was like we
can make you rich and famous you know so
and I feel like Marie and her are
supposed to represent the duality of the
path you can go down I felt like Kate
had been like villainous Tendencies and
then they just got like exacerbated like
the villainous Tendencies were planted
but compassion at villain because the
Nuance of the show and then I felt like
she realized that people would never
trust her villain like I feel like that
betrayal is what led her to be like well
if no one's going to love me I'm GNA
love what I need to yeah yeah
yeah um far talk about homelander I do
feel like Homeland what I liked about
what I loved about the homelander thing
some else is with me with the the the
dickas yeah no I've been there the whole
time that's why we thought it wasn't
real yeah I still don't know like this
guy just seems like he's just going
about life living fine um so the and I
do think the Marie and Jordan uh that
was one of my criticisms that I know
some people might not stick around fully
for our review portion uh but yeah that
was one of my criticisms about it was I
didn't really quite see why they fell in
love with each other yeah I could
understand a traction but they like
really seem to fall for each other very
suddenly and I didn't quite get that the
the and the homelander showing up um I
love the way he showed up because it
seems like he's gonna save the day and
then he that was genius that was really
well it's always what homelander wants
when like the No One controls him which
I love yeah yeah I thought that was
brilliant because that's the character
like Ashley's coming in to like stop
Kate and Sam then he goes to support
Kate and Sam they call him like why
would you do what kind of animal are you
is such a good line was great and I
wonder if the Kate Arc might feel less
rush for some people who are and maybe
I'm wrong you know really I I I I I I
think ultimately I just have a different
perspective or we do we have a different
perspective on it is that when Kate
knowing who Kate really is I wonder if
watching the season as a whole will
actually make it feel better fleshed out
versus week to week like what happened
yeah yeah yeah ex also I I someone just
said love the the short and sweet
appearance of homelander I think that's
how you grow out shows like that's how
you do a cameo that's how you have so
many characters that's how you tie it in
without making it sacrifice the show
because this didn't feel like boy light
this felt like gen V yeah all right we
have talked about it we have talked
about someone when this stream is done
write down where two hours is yeah I
think it's two hour we left for two
hours right I think so
Skyler don't worry oh no that's that's
what I I don't like I don't like being
mad at anybody that's sweet you done
up coy
what did I I you you done hurt this
man's feelings well I he hurt my
feelings on the same page I you're my I
was worried that I was a bad
person you're you're mean we were just
punching each other and look at the look
at the I apologize if I in any way uh
made overly uh generalized comments I
appreciate you I don't know if you guys
have realized kind of the structure here
chaos to the uh stream it's generally we
like we appreciate the support from the
super chats and we keep your guys'
comments on screen because the super
chats are a d are really driving the
topics and then we kind of just see to
see what uh interacts and like what you
guys are saying in the feedback and like
right now I think what you guys were
saying about genv completely helped
Drive The Narrative of how we talk so I
appreciate it yeah it helps and also it
helps us to know what people are curious
about because we can't just assume
because we have a very different
experience with this stuff yeah yeah we
have to like everything yeah ex how do I
pivot into how do I act like I
like this oh so
exhausting where' we leave
off I think MFA great name why you not
like secret Invasion Jay started strong
ended awfully um God you know it's I
forget about things way too quick it
opened with really interesting Nuance
dialogue conversations and by the end it
was literally a spoof that shehulk
referenced it was like a punch them up
now there's like super overpowered
characters there was no delivery on the
super Scrolls in any sort of threatening
way it literally just felt like they
were like oh we need Super Scrolls the
fights felt very cheap even though they
were very expensive thought there was a
lack of emotional weight there was no
emotional weight everyone dying is like
lost and wasted on the show and all of
the nuanced conversations the show
started with didn't pay off it was like
the first half of the show was one show
about like Espionage Tinker Taylor
solders spy and the second half was like
what do people like about Marvel and not
in the way that is actually warranted
the director had such a in my opinion
beautiful vision of how the show started
that didn't pay off and then the way
that things landed invalidate other
things in the MCU it's kind of like the
worst case scenario of a lot of things
for long form content did not work for
me personally yeah it ultimate and that
finale was just not that was not um
firing on all cylinders they didn't even
know how to handle revals of things like
yeah
visually a um what's her name
Maria Hill it set it up with such it set
it up to be such an important thing yeah
um and I love the conversation like the
person dialogue when I did the interview
with the director it was so like man I
love how you're doing all this nuance
and then by the end I was like so these
big armed people are punching each other
in the sky you can feel the yeah and Jo
does demystify Nick Fury I will agree
with that I think it greatly demystifies
Nick Fury and I thought in the beginning
that was interesting and by the end I
was like oh it's weightless cuz it
didn't pay off yeah it just wasn't it
wasn't uh what I what I hoped from the
beginning that's the problem with shows
versus a movie A lot of times you can
watch a movie and be like I wasn't a big
fan of the finale but man those two
thirs were really great yeah cuz that's
like 70 minutes versus but for some
reason a show your your ending takeaway
is often the last episode yeah you know
I walked away sad it's kind of crazy how
because you especially when it's week to
week yeah cuz the characters were all
great and I remember thinking like man I
love donel performance I love Olivia
Coleman in this and then by the end I'm
like yeah cuz I remember like kind of
feeling that way about dared season two
like there was a lot towards the end
that I love season two I love season two
I do I I actually un popular opinion I
like it more than season 3 um I like oh
I'm with you oh okay good yeah that I
mean the rooftop is one of the best
scenes in the history of comic books oh
yeah no I think the I think the so I'm
saying but that's in the first half of
season two yeah but I I still think
that's a better but I think that first
half is so much stronger than the last
half but I still really like the last
half it Paces itself better the first
half yeah I agree with that but man
season two it's like the courtroom stuff
the roof top chimney SC like there's so
much in season 2 I remember season 2 got
a lot of flack and I think it's cuz
everything with the hand was kind of
cheesy or whatever yeah when season one
is like so it's a high bar season one's
the best like season one of I don't even
think Loki's better than I don't think I
don't know if there's anything that
Marvel has done in the Cinematic
Universe that has matched Daredevil
season and I'd put season two above two3
of the MCU have your opinions you
everyone going to have their opinions
and that's how that's totally okay it's
the way the world is um for me
personally Daredevil season one is the
like The Best Thing Marvel has done yeah
I'd put Daredevil as all three seasons
above two-thirds of the MCU at a th%
yeah oh the rooftop scene in season two
with Punisher and Daredevil it's maybe
my favorite what a what a great debate
and that that moment is up there for me
as like Andrew Garfield returning and I
love Andrew Garfield like it's just so
good red like it's oh man I want to go
watch it right now the Alonzo P the lack
of consequences is hurting Marvel th%
yeah yeah no it it it uh yeah it
does the Avengers films built off the
consequences of the last one even
Infinity war was arguably lost because
of the uh
Captain civil war cat in the cat in the
catty wax I was just like what where's
my mind going with this Captain America
Civil War Fallout Kang has just been
collecting L's I do find it hilarious
that Kang is just dying a lot which is
why my theory of him being like killed
for time like I think maybe they get
stronger the less kangs there are I
think the time element is him getting
like pulled spaghetti wise and making
him a conqueror you do need a a
king that is the
definitive this is the one to fear the
most right which I'm hoping we get next
week you do need that because it's like
quantity game of throwing a bunch of
Kings with like good Jonathan Major's
performances are um kind of undermining
it you you do need a singularity at Le
at least to focus on even if you have
your multiverses of Kings I'm so worried
about Loki cleaning everything up and it
being like well that's done like I'm the
only thing I'm worried about with Loki
is him being able to be the god of
stories and that eliminating the stakes
of Loki season 2 because what they could
have done with the end of episode four
is allow all the multiversal stuff that
leads to Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars to
have so much weight and especially with
Deadpool in the middle like I've been
saying the whole time I think you know
obviously Deadpool's going to clean up
the fox universe but the events of
episode 4 allow for that and I'm afraid
Loki six is going to invalidate four
because of this exact thing sure sure
exactly yeah no I'm with you man um
let's see here damn we're still at 99
viewers it's pretty good beauti pretty
good for Never Going live yeah three
months is a long time it's not a thing
this channel does a lot thanks everyone
that's really good thank you um let's
see here but also I agree with you Age
of Ultron is building off the stakes of
the first Avengers and infinity War
builds off like it was escalating in in
a great way which is why I think the
multiversal thing they're different
multiverses I think but in the multivers
when youve trained your audience
especially to care about connectivity as
much as be be Champion for individuality
with your films at the end of the day
it's like well you're also you also have
10 years of connectivity you know so you
gota we're also expecting it um when you
think about the transition from Loki
season 1 to Loki season 2 the fact that
you don't need to watch any of the
countless properties that came in
between Loki season one and Loki season
2 after the ending of Loki season 1 yeah
the fact that that incident didn't have
any like a feel is a testament to a the
strength of Loki season 1 but also a
testament to the negativity of what
Marvel has been like lately when you're
like oh wait yeah we're just here and
we're fine especially because the end of
season one was like this is going to
affect everything and then we've heard
things like that moment ties exactly to
that moment if you line these two things
up that's why I'm hoping that moment is
when the Multiverse is split and like
different universes are and then we find
out later but it does feel like it's
been a while yeah I hated that Stadium
scene in I know some people love
the out of that Stadium even though
it was a frame for frame comic moment it
did not feel good so much every time I
see it it's such a joke I can't stand it
man it's a terrible scene
um I aill Christa thank you love you
such much thank you love you so much
appreciate you Kiana Chanel a look how
cute this is guys you guys see that look
how cute that can you see it she built
it herself oh that's adorable little T
perfect thank you normal MCU fan I love
the Marvel Universe and I really hope
they can start improving a lot of their
content I can't wait to see where it
goes from here moronic shills you just
hate
women oh we're
back how many rants have I been on that
I've talked about a VIN diagram I gave
visual aids I gave references I
acknowled I don't think it's an attack
against you homie this person was they
seemed very mad at me earlier this is
one of the people I thought was mad at
me I think they're making are sure
sarcastic aren't they just making a
point about how people perceive cuz you
didn't say you hate women right I don't
think I hate women no in the chat no I'm
saying do I hate women God damn it Coy
let me finish do they hate women let me
finish you hate with you were saying
you're making a point about that there
are those individuals out there that
yeah whenever a woman shows up it's an
easy clickbait of of just like I
woke yeah why is Wonder Woman about a
woman you know like like that that
happens but I think you're were also
saying that that's not really the case
for a lot of people that you can still
like we've been very critical of the
content we're still called shills yeah I
was even critical of stuff about last
episode of Loki I SP I like the majority
of my talk was a thing I had a criticism
about and and people will still say I'm
just chilling but if you watch the
review I'm like most of me talking I
even got word I was like say that t
perfect was mad at me it is someone say
I wasn't this reading that uh I I think
you can have D they just contributed to
your pay today so just let him
know I also but but other people a I
apologize if I uh was not nuanced enough
in my discussion I think you can have
reasons to dislike Marvel I think you
can also have no reasons to dislike
Marvel and just be loud they're
different things so if you are one of
those people that dislike some of the
choices Marvel's made I apologize if you
felt attacked by my
statements sir or man hold on I'm giving
an answer to uh Janelle who just showed
up saying how late am I very saying
Janelle here's what you are late to I'm
going to give you a list little
summ MH I don't know what comic nerds
being predominantly men has anything to
do with loving women or not I I know you
know decent amount of men that love
women I think that's how Humanity keeps
going just like mathematically babies
come out of men loving women and then
adopting when you know you can't make
them yourself is also very important so
we need to keep Society Alive by loving
women and protecting them it's
important there you
go there it is there it is I like it
true true sorry T perfect Spidey said
say 72 thank you will koi grow his face
back very baby going in 2024 does your
girlfriend like it no thank
God a man you showed up I was
like what have you done I I dressed as a
uh a Mattel character not a struck
company character for Halloween and um
when I dress like that character that
character does not have facial hair so I
shaved mine and um I was like I haven't
done this in four years what do I look
like and then I feared mirrors uh I
don't I it's been very intense man I'm
not used to um it and I don't intend to
keep it but I do intend to like mix it
up a little bit maybe I'll just have a
big porn stash who knows what's coming
next but I've got a clean slate and
it'll be fun my wife came up to like did
you tell Koy how horrible his face
looks guys there someone said I looked
like let me see what Coy's girlfriend
has to say someone said I looked like
Sid from The Toy Story and that I don't
see uh I got what one that I liked was
uh so someone said I look like Jesse
plem and I definitely see more like fat
matte Damon than meth Damon Like Jesse
pens is meth Damon I think I look more
like the informant um but like I I
definitely you know I'm gonna have
stubble for a bit and maybe some
mustache but it's not a it's not a
forever thing I can't grow mutton chops
I don't have uh I don't have the the
genetics oh God tutorial slave thank you
tutorial uh what time is it it's about
that time oh God okay all right guys if
you wish to contribute to the super
chats we really appreciate it I am going
to turn them off in like one minute so
we can make sure we get through the rest
because we're recording for two hours
and
15 and three hour more that's the goal
three hours we're gonna hit it but yeah
I mean the I'm I'm hon we don't finish
until then we don't that's the
rule there should either be an edge of
tomorrow king or no more than five to
six variants all of them n Unstoppable
some fleshed out in special
presentations I suppose have you guys
read the King Dynasty Arc I read that
it's so good there's this one artc that
is so Monumental it's the one where the
iconic image comes from gang Dynasty and
there's no dialogue in it I think that
such a great comic and Jackson lansing's
Kang solo that I that that you loved are
like the two must I like that way more
yeah oh I think that's the best Kang
period like hard stop I think Jackson
lansing's Kang is is the best um but I
think it's important to ring the King
Dynasty as well I I'm going to level
with you guys on something that I've
I've admitted before and I it doesn't
earn me any brownie points I'm not the
biggest fan of event comic books I I
think a lot of them are more exciting
for the idea of translating them to a
liveaction medium or or adapting them in
the show or whatever uh but generally a
live act a comic book event unless I've
really read everything that led to the
event yeah that's where that's where
it's just like it's just a bunch of
happening with no real character
development and and I need that I do
need that it's just and there's a lot of
like recapping and trying to quickly
explain other things that happened in
another issue and it's it's it's just
hopping straight into an event comic is
not my favorite thing and I know a lot
of people do that but I really like the
uh I did like the King Dynasty one and I
thought there was such a there's such a
powerful AFF effect to the one without
the dialogue where you can kind of feel
it as if you're watching something
cinematic while you're just reading it
the the silent the desolate silence and
it's impactful because of the rest of
the event but it is hard to just jump
into like two years led to this and
you're like well I uh guess I know these
guys and they know that people have not
been reading for two years so yeah so
like let's just make this work yeah
recap recap recap yeah I think it's just
like a lot of action and and action in
comics is not that exciting to me he you
know what even though I know that's the
main thing we think about when it comes
to comic book Things is action
action in comics generally is not the
most exciting thing to me in a comic
Nuance in conversation is like much like
the show is more my thing and I but I'm
with you I what's hard for me is I can
never read a comic not like someone
who's read a comic since they were two
right like when you describe your your
like immersive level I can't possibly go
like I get it because like I learned to
read with them so it's really hard when
people like what's a good Gateway comic
and I'm just like I'm going to say
Ultimate Spider-Man because other people
have shared that with me like when I say
Ultimate Spider-Man it's because I
thought was how I got back into comics
and other people have shared that with
me but I can't possibly tell you what is
approachable because my brain is like I
know these characters better than my
family right right right right right
right Deadshot thank you Deadshot Co I
wanted to say real quick you are awesome
and glad you have joined the reject
Nation wonder if you and John will be
doing more DC project reactions also
loved your interview with Yuri that's a
big maybe if the last four pick up in
views then maybe share them maybe play
them in the background have them we just
like to break even it's all we're at
there what a business model yeah uh
thank you for greedy cig I'm sorry for
wanting to break even on like on the
time it takes to put these together no
no every business should be run at a
loss uh also the Yuri uh interview means
a lot to me so thank you for watching
and thank you for sharing and people
keep sharing and
commenting uh all right I need to turn
off can I can I pee real quick is that
allow I got to it's got to happen you'll
have to use the one in the kitchen okay
and go there quietly okay I'll be right
back guys all right
guys dude I got this let's talk about
politics
guys let's go let me just refresh
everything Ki not only left the room he
also shut the door which has left me
feeling very isolated right now uh if
people come in and wondering where Coy
is please tell them that KY is in the
bathroom it's not about how many views
we all need per I'll answer this
question it's not about how many it just
depends on the time it takes uh for it
you know some people like their average
like I know some people with YouTube
channels were like if it's not getting
100K end it you know if it's not doing
this end it like one of the great things
about the reason why editing is a big
part of our channel one thing I'm super
proud of is I'm not GNA i' I've talked
with other Rea of other channels to do
reactions and one thing I've discovered
and I haven't talked with every channel
like I've never had a conversation with
like blindwave about this for example
but there's other channels I've talked
to where I see what our watch time is on
a video and YouTube really likes watch
time and our watch time is very high
compared to a lot of other reaction
channels and a lot of comes down to like
lacing the right commentary in
throughout because I I know there's like
like zavid I think is how you pronounced
his name uh fantastic React channel he
has like a lot of crazy inserts and
stuff so his editing is more involved
than our editing whereas like our
editing for I can only speak to the time
it takes me and I probably edit faster
than edit editors re H because normally
when I'm editing something it's cuz I'm
in the video too so I kind of know the
video in advance but for me like okay I
could use uh the other day as an example
Loki was about 45 minute runtime uh shot
it at 6:00 p.m. finished filming around
7:20 I got it up by midnight and that
was
rushed Five Nights at Freddy's took a
much longer time to edit because it's
Universal so you can only use use less
amount of time per a clip and you also
got to be mindful of music and all that
but generally the editing time for me
it'll take if it's a 40 to 45 minute run
time it takes anywhere from three to
four and a half hours to edit that that
that's just the editing down of the the
reaction right it's not Factory in like
thumbnails or prepping Med I'm just
talking about just the edit alone so you
can kind of give or take you know if
something is a shorter episode or
something is a movie you know like I
edited some I've edited some movies here
as well and
a lot it just depends so it's not really
even about like ideally you'd like to
get more than like 30k views or
something like that but if you're if
you're committing to something and
you're seeing that like the watch time
is not that high because you can make
more speaking on just a very direct
manner when it comes to
YouTube you can have some videos like we
can have a video that has a movie
reaction with 30,000 views make more on
AdSense than a video that is 8 minutes
long but has 100,000 views because
people might be watching that 30k VI one
for 20 minutes which means better ad
Revenue that's and and I think that we
always earned that because there's so
much work put into the editing to
Warrant having people watch for that
long time and so it's not really about
views it's that's why that's why I use
the term are we breaking even on this
you know and then when you're not when
you're like okay the views are not that
great what's the watch time watch time
has been going down to okay then it's
not really worth doing that's why like
like Superman and Lois wasn't and
cutting it after the time and effort was
taken uh Chucky and and then
unfortunately the last like four with
John and course DC animated stuff and so
that's like there's so because if I'm
not editing it then someone else is
editing then you got to pay that person
to edit that then we're involved with
the re-edits there's always these people
like it's this big like Hub per
video Yeah versus like a trailer
reaction which I know we don't do a lot
of anymore um you know like we shot that
at what 9:30 yeah I had that up by like
1110 you know so that's like way shorter
but it was because it was 2 minutes it
was 1 minute 55 seconds plus commentary
yeah yeah yeah um so even just the
thumbnail guys you got to realize like
the volume of work that goes even just
like narrowing down images because it
has to be clickable like the thumbnail
is something I didn't realize till I
started working with Greg is like it has
to be approachable it has to be
something that it draws you in it also
has to be accurate you have to find that
the frame thumbnails are insane they
take as long as the video are longer uh
also I did wash my hands and they're not
it0 bitty I've actually got
disproportionately big hands for for a 5
foot gu but I saw you all right the last
Super gloves we got some super chats to
go through as we end this keep the chat
going guys leave a like on this video if
you haven't done so already we didn't
skip Skyler did we no no we got more to
go through okay good I I I'm I'm saying
that you can no longer you can
contribute stickers but you can't
contribute super chats right now because
it turned it off to make sure we can get
through the
last my stamina for this is
gone down a little bit we AG
slow uh I have not played Spider-Man 2
yet I don't own a PS5 but I hope to one
day maybe over the holidays maybe it's
nice see them in Target now yeah yeah
well they're just they're just they're
just not free is the problem they can be
oh five finger discount have you seen
unfriended dark web uh no well well here
we go I gotta sell Fe picks for cry
there um let's see let's see C pal cross
PL Nation hello C pal fans good Fells a
great reac action COI thank you I had
never seen good I think a new tradition
will be my last day of whatever year
before my birthday watching a classic I
haven't seen it was really fun all right
Co new sag after update someone put that
in the chat trying to get arms like COI
get after it zips all right okay Archie
Adams thank you how do you think the TVA
will coexist with the spider society as
that is now linked also how many other
Spider-Man do you think we will see in
secret rewards Beyond Toby Andrew and
Tom could be see 299 how cool would it
be if we got Oscar Isaac to play
Spider-Man 299 live action
boy and then he interacts with moonight
and then they all just team up with
apocalypse from
Fox I think I think Secret Wars is the
only movie you can get away Secret Wars
needs to be like two movies if they are
going to go crazy gung-ho with Cameo I
think they should split it yeah I think
it should be two movies and I think they
should go as Cameo heavy as the people
expect because it's not like it's not
even a want now it's a demand because if
we saw the Multiverse like Fallout I
think they have to go hard unless
there's 700 people in it people are and
I do think they should Reserve X-Men for
after that way you have something to get
people excited I think they'll have
multiversal X-Men in Deadpool and Secret
Wars and I think the secret Wars ends
with new X-Men yeah that way I think
it's a launching point that you can be
excited for so after what are you g to
do after Secret Wars new universe and I
think with the way people have reacted
to to phase five and six is they're
going to I think that Fantastic 4 X-Men
they need to focus on the new characters
I think that there's a lot of baggage
with this run because of the pandemic
because of the strike because of the old
era I think it's going to be a kind of a
soft reboot yeah I agree with you
Muhammad I mean I feel like Marvel put a
lot of emphasis on like well Echo didn't
do good but it was tvma so we shouldn't
do that anymore I am a little worried
about that stupid I think that's dumb
when people do that I'm hoping the Hulu
Disney plus combination boost is enough
but we'll see donard 88 I know you're
enjoying Loki but as am I as am I but
how do you think they can mess you the
finale what what does that mean hey
Kelly what does that mean um I don't
know I mean mess up the finale I think
they could have what I described earlier
like no ramifications like Loki being
able to fix everything by like going
through time uh I think they could have
a another limp Kang um I think that they
could mess it up by having it not lead
to the next wave of Marvel so we feel
like it doesn't matter I think a lot of
the shows have felt kind of weak because
they didn't feel like you know they had
wait for the movies so I think they
could mess it up by you know it living
in itself kind of like Loki season one
is exceptional but like Greg said the
events at the end of Loki season
one so we need to start seeing that that
weight for it to
matter does that does that answer it I
think that answer yeah I totally think
you answered it okay good you meant
messed up oh got it yeah so I think
that's how yeah I think I think that's
how they can mess up the finale because
it I mean we'll we'll find out this
week feel like we should have drawn that
conclusion ragged
wreck thank you for your moment of
silence my
friend Sky the
magnoni 8 wow what a name what about
Marvel hiring Chad stahelski Nicholas
Winden Reen Shaka King Gareth Evans and
Noah Holly to direct certain projects
much love so they can come out and talk
about how they didn't have freedom I
feel like you're I feel like you're way
more likely to get David Leech to direct
a Marvel movie than you are Chad
stahelski at this point see for the guys
who forget Chad stahelski for some
reason is only directed John Wick movies
but Chad stahelski and and David Leech
they co-directed the first John Wick
movie together after that it was only
Chad stahelski and you could kind of see
what David like I think John Wick one
had more of a self-awareness comedy to
Joy they're all good but there was a joy
in one yeah yeah and and even though it
has like the most personal Darkness
about him it's still there was a comedy
angle to it right and and I love leech's
bullet train comedy I thinky looks great
it's just funny how leech just was like
I'm just going to do action comedies now
like I'm going to do bullet train do
Hobs and shum deadpol too I know he did
Atomic blonde and and I think David
Leech uh he likes to do these like it's
just weird because David because like
John Wick is so well known for its
grounded Focus nature of its action and
David Leech do he's like a time man
super CGI movies he uh he was on one of
my flights recently and I had a Deadpool
hat on and I've done some stunt stuff
with David Leech for press and I've like
talked to him a number of times but it
was really funny that I didn't realize I
was wearing a Deadpool hat cuz you don't
like think of that so I was like just
standing in line and like we had this
talk and then I was like oh yeah and
like you know everything like Deadpool
and like I was praising it like I was
like a professional and then all of a
sudden I was like oh he he the Hat I
like I was branded I like made a fool of
myself cuz he did Deadpool 2 in a way
that I feel like would lend itself more
to the MCU uh but uh magnanimous is that
word means like ging along with everyone
and like doing stuff like a like a like
Cappy bar is magnanimous so Sky the
magnanimous um I think but I to the
point though I would I do think uh David
Le should be a great um no I'm not
saying bullet train I don't want to
sound like that I'm saying he just does
bigger movies that often involve more
CGI than than I would have expected from
the guy made John wior and Nicholas
winding refin seems like he's making
he's he's doing the opposite like he's
making it would be bad yep and then
shock and King I'm not sure they would
want to not make that feels like it's
personal uh and then Gareth Evans maybe
but after the Creator I doubt because it
seems like he's trying to steer away
from that sort of thing uh and Noah
Holly you know he had that Doom property
that Gareth Edwards Gareth Edwards at
the crater yeah Gareth Evans is uh raid
oh I don't know I get it confused I
might be wrong about that could be wrong
Ronin unchain what's up buddy get it's
your name hi Greg and Coy y going to La
ComiCon Coy does not know how to skip La
ComicCon actually might be skipping La
ComicCon yeah me too I don't give a
about like ComiCon I mean I don't
have any gigs booked for it I don't
really even care about San Diego ComiCon
yeah um I don't know I think maybe uh if
someone like books me but as of now I'm
supposed to be going to Portland to uh
see a
concert wow I've never been to Portland
wow you don't love Comics I don't you
just you just you don't really love
Comics yeah what's a comic you're just
like oh I only go someone books me this
is a job to you I mean I you don't want
to go so you can buy overpriced comics
yeah I was going to say like I it's just
it's kind of like work so if I don't get
paid for work I would I do work whatever
man some I want to go to Portland you're
a sellout
yeah are we talking about how hot koyi
is apparently not apparently not there's
a lot of people very mad at so I'm not
I'm so sorry for shaving also wanted to
say to continue my previous chat
Deadshot says I am a big Spider-Man fan
I had a lot of rough times anything
think Spider-Man would help me I grew up
with all three Spider-Man and no way
home made me cry yeah dude yeah yeah
that's a beautiful film it really is I I
to this day um it's it's still my number
one Marvel film because of Spider-Man
being the same for me uh Spider-Man is
how I learned to read Spider-Man is How
I Learned I think to be a good person
and and Spider-Man's always been my guy
it took a long time for people to
eventually come on the hate train for
that movie but I still think it's a
brilliant film yeah well I mean
it's it's popular so it's something you
are supposed to hate Greg I mean like at
the last half I think is significantly
better than the first half but still as
fun as hell yeah Serena
quas hey hey Serena been watching for
years and it's been great so fun more
more of all the great addition to the
channel especially Koy sending love
thank you glad Koy can be here he was
the first real expansion real
addition I said now bring on a bunch of
other people now yeah let's go make it
exciting then dilute his impact yeah no
I I literally I do a lot of work for a
lot of channels and I remember there was
like five lives ago where I was like
this is my favorite one for these
reasons and everyone was like he hates
those other places you can have a
favorite without hating the other ones
but I I truly I feel like real rejects
is uh is my home and I appreciate it a
that's
sweet but you can't live here I know I
tried found
me actually Olivia found me and she was
like guys get off my lawn literal yeah
Cory thank you for watching for so long
hey Corey everything I'm seeing about
Ekko seems promising the announcement
you know we could always read it's here
it I keep wondering we just keep looking
over here but it's in front of us it's
the profile and then the the the direct
the announcement of Marvel spot light
also has me excited can you raise your
chair sure I feel like we're two and a
half hours in and you just look shorter
than me and I don't like feeling
Superior to you oh that's kind there we
go how's that that's better well now I
feel Superior to there we go how's that
now I like that better I guess we're equ
cool all right there it is I
guess he's promising the announcement of
Marvel SM me excited if eeko was good
then I hope for that
label what label uh Marvel Spotlight oh
Marvel Spotlight yeah sorry guys it's
two and a half hours in brains are fuzzy
I thought you were just mentioning the
the concept the concept like the
spotlight on Marvel yeah yeah no no I I
think the Marvel Spotlight concept is
genius uh I think it's really going to
be a way to distinguish which things are
must watches for the theatrical
experience versus like highlighting
characters I think it's a lot like
Marvel Knights or like any of the
imprints that have done well Marvel I
think it's really really nice um I don't
know I Chris Smith I don't like every
channel I'm on I mean I like every
channel I don't have a favorite for you
he did he's been trying the whole time
uh it worked I I think that they all
have different things and yes this chat
is mean but all chats are mean because
I'm on the Internet it's a horrible job
but uh I think that Marvel Spotlight is
going to be very important for
distinguishing different elements of
what Marvel is and that way people feel
like they're not overwhelmed necessarily
and also I think they'll give it
different flavors better experimental
choices I also feel like it's the first
choice that feels directly akin to James
gun taking over DC when I read Marvel
Spotlight I was like oh so now Kevin fog
is looking at what DC is doing and we're
starting to see that competition I I've
been wanting this forever DC doing well
makes Marvel do well makes them both do
better because they're trying to compete
Spotlight feels like oh they're going to
take some chances at DC let's take some
chances at Marvel they've been taking
chances but I think it's gon to be
stronger hey hey what's Marvel Spotlight
Marvel Spotlight is a uh a specific
brand that is in conjunction with Marvel
Studios that is more about uh ground
level heroes or more darker different
elements of Heroes um so it'll be things
that aren't directly tied into like The
Avengers like if you watch a Marvel
Spotlight you won't be confused to watch
like Avengers n so it's uh it's kind of
like an imprint in the comic book
sense Jeff Carol Chrisman totally got me
uh we've had a lot of videos get taken
off of YouTube in those ran R days Matt
a lot one was a sketch that I
loved sketch that I like the I made
edited everything and uh it got taken
down that's that's
rough someone missed my comic rexs in
this channel well I think when the when
the world's back to spinning there'll be
a place for qu comic again that's up to
Great this is semi it for
now I I need you here I can't do
this I the I don't know Marvel
Spotlight
is Killian Murphy and rdj's performance
were rightly prais in Oppenheimer but I
also feel like Benny safy was highly
underated too also loved him a good time
who do you think he could play in the
MCU Benny safy in the MCU he could play
Solomon Grundy in the
DCU could play Ben safy in the MCU you
know that is no no no I don't know who
he is I can't think of anybody though
he's uh good time and uh he's a director
yeah he's co-director of good time as
well yeah he's a brother to in a good
time he's in Oppenheimer as the the
scientist that like pushes things over
over the edge he's got that really
interesting face big brows yeah yeah
trying to think of a character that's
got cir said
hi uh that is a funny insult I'm the
type of guy to review frozen pizza that
is so funny I love that very much this
Douro is a 4.3 um answer the question I
just said you're here for a reason
Brainiac do it Coy is fun for
DC uh Benny safy has maggot in the X-Men
okay sorry Benny safy you just got to
look you could play jigsaw hey that's
not bad oh that is f he's a really
talented actor just like he's got a very
specific face he could I like that
tombstone's good I like that oh man they
were such cowards in um in Punisher
season two oh yeah they kept him so
handsome I was like I feel like this
makes him more like better looking yeah
like no no there's a more of a mystery
to it like what happened to this guy
he's just like more interesting like i'
be like this guy's got a story yeah they
they they cow were such coward it was
just like cuz that actor is also like a
staggeringly handsome guy they're like
scratches I thought it was great to cast
him in the first season cuz you're like
oh man they casted someone who was like
so obviously beautiful and they're going
to ruin him and that point there's a
duality but there wasn't and and then
the whole season he was like I'm so ugly
like are you oh Benny sa you for Beast
is fun I like that James that's clever
yeah put him makeup cam plays
hey cam wish moonnight for the tvma
first hey you know what they should have
had Loki for the
tvma that should be alt Universe we're
the
tvma universe these jokes only get
better it's just Owen Wilson walk around
wow good
jokes uh I think uh I think moonnight I
said it in our Echo trailer I think the
violence in the trailer for Ekko was
more violent than Moon Knight's entire
run and moon Knight's like one of those
was insanely violent character so it
would have been nice I enjoyed a lot of
moonight but um you know I think there's
also elements of uh cutting away that
worked narratively and also like we need
to save the rating what up Jack uh so I
think that's
important
Quaid no he's he's not he's not in La
that's not Jack Quaid it's not it's Jack
Fern I assume I think it's Jack Fern
what up maybe it's Quaid jenv was great
Jack what if it's what if it's qu I'm
gonna look up if he owns kinetic films
it'd be funny it might be I know he
watches the channel been on it be like
what an Jack Wade come on be Tu
V in
here
SE thank you sayon thank you for the
question hey Greg will chal is lamonaco
it's Lam Monaco Lam Monaco be back on
the channel soon I think you and are a
great chemistry on camera oh man well I
love Sally and I we're just trying to
figure it out it's just a little bit
hard she's been working on some other
stuff and then filming remotely with
someone's always way more complicated
than filming in person obviously there's
a whole bunch of let's talk signific
about like editing whole of like
Technical and then you got like secure
connections it becomes like a whole mess
when you're trying to record properly
you got to get that footage you got it's
so there's just reasons why that we we
haven't but um I would love to film with
her again so I made an appearance for
Spider-Man film last time she was out
here she stayed with us she's great she
she's a love love s it's my
actor buddy Jack marulu who I just saw
on the picket lines last week not Quaid
who was also on the picket lines uh Jack
was like literally at the other side of
of Paramount we were there Jack well I
don't know you jack Millo yeah so there
so good guy just got married congrats
let's oh congratulations we hang out
married people only hang out with
married people let's let's look up Jack
morillo like how he's doing look at that
handsome guy is that him yeah damn look
at this handsome devil truly look at
that guy doing the work holy
you just made a fan oh my God wait
a minute I know your face yeah he's like
a good working actor I've seen him in
stuff yeah let's go to your IMDb also a
sweetheart good fellow and everyone look
up Jack
Millo get that star meter up this is
this is what influencing is oh we're
influencing Jack millo's career let's
get I want to help people I know so
let's do it all right all right he was
in Seal Team yep oh Call of Duty is
worked on Call of Duty bunch of them oh
my God Jane the Virgin yep doing the
work I mean you we're influencing in
real time influencing this how you do it
Jack gillo is my new favorite actor he's
also a director and a writer and he's
really in shap graduated from strawberg
theater Jesus hustling doing the work my
God repres by CA protesting on the front
lines everyone you show some respect to
Jack
merillo is he in the chat hope so we
been just giv him all that oh yeah I
should show him on screen so sorry let
me just slide other people are we got to
slide the DM public slide him in here
really quick I like the real time
influencing yeah this this called
influencers yeah for influencers well
look at him look at him hands face doing
the work look at him look at him
everyone look at him well that's not him
anymore there a cou yeah this the Jack
Millo fan club that's that's I like it I
like it all right that's what I'm
talking about baby Jack durillo has a
different last name Jas Dillo yeah me we
gave him all that some real plugin come
on now if there's a cast director in the
chat hire this handsome man all right
all right we're back all right far how
much more do we have here who knows we
keep I mean that tangent was clearly
warranted all right Co we can do this in
18 minutes all right watch watch
efficiency
boom Oh Boy all right efficiency coming
in Coy get ready to be efficient oh we
can do it all right Joe o'keef gretings
from Dublin orand just wanted to say you
guys are wonderful people haven't
interacted with much last chicken and S
me love I uh I'm sorry to you and all my
ancestors for what just happened what
are you talking about man I honor I was
like hearing home I honored you that was
that was like a I tow up in the morning
to little taste a home that was uh much
love back to Dublin I was supposed to go
there this year but I did not make it
and I very
bummed the oh there's a bicep check uh I
think uh uh Perle blue those are the
anyway um I am very excited to get
back to Dublin I love that City very
much and uh poachin is my favorite
beverage on the planet it's hard to find
in America it's even harder to find in
Dublin because it's illegal there but if
you know the right bars you let me know
next time back and much love back that
accent was no
tragic put the F get
to it's like someone doing a Conor
McGregor doing a Lucky Charms impression
it's like layers of I know man it's
versatility look at this guy oh I'm
sorry to hear about that
Aaron much love much love to you man
I've lost a parent it's terrible
feeling wait till you go through it I uh
I I will be busy that day I ouch
32 brings it personally brings the mve
out and then insult to injury remember
people saying com book fatigue in 2016
yeah you're all wrong the next year we
got Guardians of the Galaxy 2 Thor four
really that was Thor four I don't think
so man thunder came out in 2017 we're
still ating on it
Spiderman Irish
offended and suddenly a te was gone
quality will save comic book movies and
not only that you got to release all
comic book properties on the same week
uh yeah yeah same day preferably if you
can have the all the things come out the
same day on a Thursday perhaps that'll
be great um yeah I uh I agree I think
there's phases of of uh going through
hate for a thing that's doing well and I
think that I know people are gonna be
like it's not doing well you can look at
a 20% drop and all those things you can
also look at the giant box off is still
compared to other movies it's not dying
but it is not what it was in 2016 and I
do think it'll EB and flow I think we're
just an EB superhero
fatigue know what that
is's what's the what's the guy in
eternals the fair yeah is that is is
that his name the is his name
that's there are a lot of Irish Mexicans
why like a bean
burrito definitely two
giant
RAC man you really truly
wasel
please oh two hours and 40 minutes into
a stream it's just unte just now it's
stereotype how many amalgamation
stereotypes can be thrown a one thought
was offensive earlier by thinking people
didn't like women here's Greg pulling
out the Irish Mexican
accents back at hey C was asking about
comparing American death domestic
opening stop of a
movie versus global opening when
commentators predicting success of a
film what your com your Clarity is
making me more confused my friend but I
love a Super Chat oh why the American
opening versus the global is is more
important to I think it's more important
to American and also because Hollywood
is um trying to keep Hollywood as
important to them like I feel like you
know I imagine Bollywood has the uh
Indian box office first as a foundation
I think it's just like you know it these
are the American films we're talking
about the American box office and the
worldwide box office but it starts with
the the domestic I I imagine yeah kind
of it depends it depends on the property
that's true cuz some films do much
better in Balance internationally some
people just really care about getting in
that overseas Market you know yeah and
like I think the Transformers films you
know exceeded expectations there I think
what Avatar was was really big overseas
so I think it all depends on what you're
I think it's a business tactic to make
your movie sound better like if it did
great domestically lean domestic um but
yeah I think I mean yeah like like Tom
Cruz man uh international audities love
Tom Cruz so they really try to like tend
to that you know and the US market is
huge I think the Chinese market is is
like second biggest India is bigger than
americ they've been losing interest in
our though man yeah every Chinese
person disinterested just I could speak
for all Chinese people Coy do your best
Chinese accent nope now do it hello I'm
from China God Chinese accent coward
world to sensitive when a white man in a
live stream can't do a Chinese impers
just did a great one hello I'm from
China
handled I moved here States when I was
one years old I was raised with people
that spoke just like me and here I
am Tom Cruz was Irish and fart away
thank you for changing the subject for
me Trey Porter hey Trey bluee
Samurai it's a really great show on
Netflix it just came out yesterday
there's too much television that's why
I'm watching Whose Line is in
anyways it's safer that way yeah uh but
I'm sure it's good saw your chat a
couple times I just I have too many too
many shows I'm so behind I haven't even
watched like Dairy girls which I hear is
very much my jam um I need to watch a
lot but there's I just don't know if
that's second to happen I've been
wanting to watch better call Salt oh man
such a great show I've been wanting to
watch the continental and I'm like
that's only three things three episodes
I got to watch yeah what like four hours
total I haven't even finished Barry yeah
I'm like five episodes away from
it Attack on Titan last last episode
come out today your thoughts my thoughts
are I am eventually going to watch it
this month those are my thoughts I
promise but they appreciate the Super
Chat and the inquiry your your overall
interest it means a lot thank you
heather gear Heather gear ultimate deer
that I hold near and dear do not fear
she brings so much
cheer and um reindeers live have you
seen the deer hunter nope oh wow what a
fun movie fun oh yeah dude so fun all
right
yeah should I Rea to the deer hunter
never wished I was in the Vietnam World
War I mean it seems like a I feel like
you know so excited for I wasn't even
alive and I still hear CCR and go that
sounds rough yes yes all the thoughts on
gen V please we've given it we're lit to
your chat uh yeah I would love I I it'
be great I I want to you thinking like
January February I think we should do it
December right
before the Christian haroff one oh
that'd be so fun just hours before just
literally same place same place same
room and then encourage people be like
look there's another show coming up but
if youall want to hang out outside we're
going to get pizza we're going to go get
pizza Pro them with pizza yes into it
yep that's the move December 1st or
whatever Let's Do
It um but I appreciate you hether gear
she's one of our most loyal super sexy
rejects those are our patrons I haven't
seen the losers I mean why don't you do
a reaction to that James uh losers is
great it's a jock comic Jock's one an
artist I really do I don't have plans to
do one piece anime in the future because
the show is forever Skyler here we go
let's see what he says there we are
Skyler let's see let's see if he's
goingon to warm up to you man Moment of
Truth there was some heated debates
happening between you and Skyler earlier
have we gone on a character Arc here
perhaps he
says Co I apologize for my idiotic I
cannot believe I you know I should have
that was the delivery on the joke the
setup was there I'm still shocked this
is my shocked face I Am 2001 shocked
Cory whoa I apologize for my idiotic and
hateful comments I do appreciate your
wealth of comic knowledge I also
appreciate your world
view I I I'm still Gob smacked by the
accent hey man he loves you I I I will
say uh I appreciate the apology I I
accept and extend mine back I I really
don't want to be polarizing I it's
really hard for me because I'm a very um
I have strong opinions and I do get very
protective of people in my life like I
my mom was a 16-year-old mom I I am I
have more female friends than male
friends I tend to identify more with
women and I think that a lot of misogyny
isn't even realized by the people doing
it and I also don't think that everyone
is misogynistic and I don't think
everyone that doesn't like Marvel is but
I think there's a lot of it in our
culture and I think there's a lot of
subtle racism that I'm trying to see
more and more in like what you talk
about
cor like certain accents to intro
apologies and got on this W man but
I I honestly I honestly am trying to not
be so polarizing and I'm honestly trying
to uh not have people I don't think that
a a diametrically which is the word of
this episode uh AOS viewpoints are ever
going to come together but I also think
there is more Middle Ground between
people than they want to cuz it is
easier to hate so thank you for your
apology I extend mine back and I hope uh
I hope we're cool
bag love every single one of
you to say there SE so many new movies
just so I can watch your reactions keep
them coming a thanks man that's cool
that's I like when I hear people I like
when I hear people say uh that we can
like I I like that I've done that I've
done that like many time like sometimes
I don't want to hear a review or or
watch yeah I don't and sometimes I their
channels like that I like to listen to
like uh no man I haven't edible in a
while that sounds great now he's got
afternoon playing Ser seriously my god
um that would be lifechanging right
about
now the I just haven't been sleeping
lately I slept today and but it's like
you know your body just needs like I
need to days you hear about you hear
about coma and you're like that sounds
nice I'm like wow what a break
like like these people take their com
they got 40 days of just I go into
hospitals and I just yell at those
grieving
people you don't know what you have
yeah
anyway this end this end of thread is
just wow but no like like like red like
weekly Planet uh my favorite podcast
cast they always do a spoiler review for
the anything they're covering sometimes
like I want to hear it I should watch
this movie though yeah so I can no you
know so that makes that makes me happy
that makes me really happy honestly
thank you Melvin Emanuel Rodriguez we
are not going to re appreciate the Super
Chat appreciate the inquiry are you guys
going to react to um Superman and Lois
season
3 no we're not no it's too late there's
a reason they're canceling the
show joking
I'm joking I've entered this phase of
the live stream it's crazy CW out it's a
great show yeah it's a great show it
really is and and one day I'm just going
to continue it on my own you know it's
crazy that the CW was the superhero
Network and now they're out that's that
was the last CW like the DC show it's
crazy they're just like and I know it's
gonna have stuff on HBO and everything
it's just insane to think about like
we're living through such a big phase
shift CW my entire childhood like
Smallville on totally like I love
Smallville so it's crazy to think we
start start with Smallville I do like
that we have symmetry it's started with
Smallville end with Superman Lois it's
just crazy to think about and that's
going to kick off the DCU with Superman
Superman yeah phases Alonzo P we got a
coin the Arcane have you not seen Arcane
no shows oh man I you would love Arcane
is it is it like a critical Roll Show
isn't it based off like a critical roll
campaign or something or am I think it's
a it's a video game property oh okay
yeah still I just I've never play the
game I don't know anything about the
game okay um but the show is phenomenal
yeah the show is phenomenal it's some of
the best animation you'll ever see I uh
for like a show I was like wow this is
really good like it's a gorgeous looking
show yeah I mean I I canceled my Netflix
a while ago why because I think they're
like money hungry and shitty to art oh
being such a I just Netflix
what they don't have any good new
content I don't know
him I'm glad people like it they're part
of the evil so is everything we consume
true but I only restart stuff when
there's something I want so I'm not P
Disney's horrible oh the worst they're
all horrible yeah who still I don't want
to support the horrible ones that aren't
aren't giving me I like I'm gonna
only pick the ones that are giving me
I like one
piece see now I turn on the chat I don't
know not my thing
I just I mean they're dude you got to
chill out Netflix is Netflix is a big
one of the people that's like keeping
the the strike going they're one of the
big people that is keeping residuals
from being shared they're giving a lot
of people a lot of money to make garbage
that's flooding the market they ruin the
exhibition industry I don't with
Netflix dude dude we got to wrap this up
in a few minutes right and I'm rounding
you to three I don't even care if we go
to four okay we you got to wrap this up
Kawai for reaction on the Fortress with
Christopher Lambert hey man that would
be something I love Chris
Lambert that' be something you know
Chris Lambert yeah he's great Highlander
there can be only one raen yeah the
Doomer thank you the Doomer I'm be fine
with know gen V talk will it was here
around the two hour mark check
back people are on my side of
Netflix that's right I use rocket money
you for Rocket money the like mint
mobile app kind of thing where it like
keeps track your money yeah yeah I was
like damn I hav been for so much
and I didn't use rocket money to
cancel any of it
yet I was like that sounds timec
consuming I check my money every five
days I literally have like an OCD about
checking all my accounts I know if I've
ever gotten like a fake charge and
I like have that on I just monitor like
paying like make sure bills are paid and
and like the people that show up here
and that's you're like else like things
show a um I don't even know
what this app is uh Aisha Kenya hey dear
so happy to see handsome Fellas on the
live again well it's happy to see your
beautiful face on our live again fun
question for you guys you're gifted 20
SE 20 C each of better help to give to
one hero one villain who do you pick oh
that's fun well have you seen the apros
uh no okay you have an around F and uh
means no no I was trying to think about
what you I've seen some of
it I was got to think about it defend
himself yeah no
hey this person's got the idea stranger
things five hits and if they start
paying their people I will subscribe
again my favorite interaction with John
uh oh I'm G tell you guys my favorite
interaction with John right
here it's true I too rich to worry about
things I go throw money around throw
money at all these
companies right
off it's it's a right off for me too
it's it's about the Integrity of them
not pay he like I guess I'll give it to
this company instead of the US
government which is another company so
yeah of the my favorite interaction with
JW is still my favorite is is um I was
like hey have you seen the longest yard
and he said uh which one the Bert
Reynolds one or the Adam Sandler one and
I said the Adam Sandler one he's like no
and I like oh have you seen the Bert
Reynolds one he's like no and I said why
didn't you just say I haven't seen the
longest yard
then that's so I'll never forget it cuz
like that's summarizes an inter
beautiful joh just like just say you
haven't seen oh that's amaz that is a
johnis why have me clarifi why go
through the loops why are we going
through this dance it's very cute that
he took the time to process John I love
how John thinks because he's always so
wholesome that I see how we got there
all right we gotta answer this Coy R you
three hours 20 sessions one's going to
John John would be the villain of my
story uh no I would I would okay I
brought Sopranos for a reason because
Sopranos a a a great lesson in Sopranos
is yes let's have that be shown for John
a great lesson in Sopranos is um um
there's some people where therapy will
not be effective you could be a
sometimes it be a great psychological
study but that doesn't mean they're
going to change sure you know maybe they
makes them more aware but it doesn't
mean they're going to change okay um
like if you're such a sociopath to a
certain point you know like I love like
those psychological interviews those
real life conversations with the serial
killers and stuff I I eat that up
sure but I'm not like I'm not here to
listen to how they're going to change as
human beings isn't them
improving state so so all that's to say
I wouldn't give it to homelander sure I
don't feel like there's a chance for
homelander to change uh but someone who
could really I would give it to Peter
Parker honestly I think Peter Parker
great one he could use some therapy for
sure Peter Parker is always about the
weight of the like struggling with
balance the weight of the world on his
shoulders responsibility he's got a lot
of trauma he never has time for himself
always for other people dealing with
that MJ just nagging on his
goddamn back all the time like get off
his back
marriage I love Mary Jan and Peter's
relationship I'm trying to think of a
moment that happened and I'm like I F uh
what's it called though I Yuri and I
talking about that in the interview we
did was one of my favorite things like
him thinking his responsibility was too
strong plug uh for like the character
and how he identified with that because
that's like a thing for me too is I
identify with like over responsibility I
feel like Magneto would be a great one
to give um he defitely do WAFF yeah yeah
I feel like there'd be hope for
Magneto I'm gonna go with Jean Gray I
think she could use some therapy oh yeah
it's great I think Jean Gray like
turning into the Phoenix is a lot of
builtup things that could have been like
work through yeah uh and that's my hero
and then my villain is going to
be
uh Omega Red I always feel like could
could be better I always feel like Omega
Red like never gets a Redemption Arc and
I feel like he was raed raed in a bad
environment and maybe if he just talked
it out he'd kill less people the lokis
don't need therapy all he needs to do is
see a recap of his life have a one
conversation with Mobius and be like
here's why I care about friends I me
friends yeah those are my two
uh Emanuel Rodriguez I think parts of
the thank you Emanuel I think parts of
the article like the Marvel's pre-sales
or Marvel panicking about the negative
reception of the shows and movies is
true but certain parts were called to
Accurate like blades many writers all it
takes is one thing to poke a hole into
completely question The credibility of
everything it's like if someone if you
if you learn about one lie someone tells
that makes you question the validity of
their entire truth yeah and that can be
the same can be said for the blade thing
with the many writers like that could
very well be true I have a hard time
believing that there was a a scenar like
when I heard it I was like really what I
don't care how much Progressive
pandering something does I don't see
fourth lead world do you do where you
make that the fourth yeah I don't
understand where that would exist like
that sounds insane insane to me that
consider that like his mom is the only
like main female character in Blade
history so it' be and not only is it a
weird one to say that about but like I
can't think of a female blade character
much less someone that could take three
of them before him so yeah I definitely
don't I don't buy that Artic yeah that
sounds like that sounds like crazy
nonsense um Honeybadger is a great pick
kilmonger Jason Todd all excellent
choices good comiing
everyone respect why is it so hard to
make a blade movie I I mean just watch
the old ones like they're great I know
like it seems really weird to not go
also the new blade comic is so good
there's your comic wreck for the episode
guys the new blade comic so good people
have been pointing out there's some n
audio credit at the end of episode 5 of
Loki it's just the uh it's the the
arcade machine saying something oh what
does it say I don't remember maybe it
was important I missed it I heard it
when we were watching it was a zaniac
sound bite oh Brandon T Hera thank you I
think you should do a watch series
series of the old kung fu theater movies
executioners wheel on meals butterfly
and sword actually I've seen
executioners I've seen none of them okay
executioners is actually the sequel to
The heroic trio oh and uh both star
Michelle yo and Maggie Chong all right
all right oh what is her name it's not
aita God what the is her name I
forget what it is uh damn she she plays
Jackie Chan's mom and legend of drunken
master um this is a big old blind spot
for me I'm going to own that oh they're
great films man they're superhero movies
but like with great wire work and not I
like when I Fu film get in front of me I
just don't typically put them great
films um wheels on meals Jackie Chan Sam
o hung Benny the jet that's where he has
his super famous fight scene with Benny
the jet Benny and the Jets uh that is a
great great that's one of my favorite
fight scenes of all time I haven't seen
the Shogun trailer but I'm interested
her looks awesome U but I haven't seen
another bof flying sword uh but yeah
that' be fun actually it' be cool to
check out some of those Jay see when
people talk about like great fight
scenes and I'm like I don't know
man you guys didn't grow up on Kung Fu
Cinema like there's there's some Kung Fu
Cinema that you guys have not seen or
you're just like or Asian Cinema in even
today Asian Cinema like you're like
that's where a lot of the great fight
scenes are actually located is over
there Jay forgot how Hawkeye existed
till the Echo trailer wonder what's
going on with Hawkeye Bishop Marvel who
gives a I know Jeremy's acent
probably factors in hope it's okay maybe
maybe it factors
in uh it says you died inert a coin
loser uh is what the the post says damn
my wife needs help I got to end this
soon uh I hope there's more I think K
Bishop is a great character as much as I
didn't love the show I loved her
character and I love her relationship
with Jeremy rener I hope we get to see
more of them and I hope rener is doing
great Andre's character development is
underrated Mustafa job in genv oh thank
you I was like uh underrated under
underrated how's he underrated he does a
pretty great Arc every time he's in a
serious mode he's going to look forward
and speak here I'm do my American accent
I got
powers hope that actor doesn't watch
re uh I think he has a decent I hope he
watch he the only one ACC impersonate
maybe it'll go better oh yeah I think I
think he has a good Arc I don't know if
it's underrated but I I don't know I
haven't seen a lot of the commentary on
Jin to be honest I haven't followed
it a lot of people think that Rush Hour
was Jackie Chan's first movie those
people wow whoop whoop his first movie
obviously weapon I would be upset by
your comment if I didn't get that that
was a Chandler
reference Greg is whipped for real oh
dude happy wife happy life and no it's
actually a fair exchange she's forcing
me to say
that you said the quiet part out loud
Skyler Loki season
too hey it's your best Fred hey handles
the characters very well um Casey being
revealed as the alcatra escap you Frank
was really did not I mean John picked up
that it was alcat right away didn't
realize it was a real life person until
someone point that I yeah is playing a
real life Escape like Loki being DB
Cooper in season one that is clever
maybe not as famous John's got those
great deep cut PS where I'm always like
what a thing to know yeah when he was
like hey have you seen the VK and you're
like which B Reynolds to the neither he
knows which what they are he does know
no but that's that's a deep pull that's
impressive hope John's watching three
hours in uh I also keep wondering if
Casey was named for King the Conqueror I
keep feeling like those letters are
important but I gonna be we'll see we'll
see marz Productions Co counting every
minute that he's losing here hey man you
it was only 15 minutes you got an hour
for what was that trailer the
one that's doing exceedingly well Eko
hey there's only minutes of your time
that's not true and you got an hour that
was it was like 40 minutes of my time
how we came we sat we talked we filmed
we
talked
like it counts friendship I don't have
any real friends marade Productions he
counts marade Productions Jesus Jesus
man thank you for your MOA
silence I was actually cting the drive
which is funnier cuz that's the idea
that like Greg him on the clock on the
clock once I leave so every everyone who
goes to work every moment I don't get
paid for my driving in my 5:00 hour
track jeos you deal with me in St
Francisco and you pay me accordingly
Rick Al how's it going buddy any ideas
to what the actual plot of Secret Wars
will be besides the vague concept of
world's colliding battle World C of the
universe or is that just what the whole
movie would be coy what is your plot
pitch for Secret Wars uh the events of
Deadpool 3 cause the universe to realize
that other universes are colliding and
that the only way to stop it is to those
other universes I think there's going to
be a bit of a prime timeline element
introduced slowly through that in Kang
Dynasty I think by the time we get to
Kang Dynasty we realize how much power
Kang has if they still go at that route
we realize that Kang is able to conquer
all time and he's able to like solve all
of his problems by eliminating any
threats so we have to by the end of Kang
have a more powerful entity than Kang I
imagine that's going to be Doom uh then
we're going to have basically Secret
Wars being how do you deal with a
multiversal threat when your multiverses
are colliding so it's the combined might
of all the universes we've met so far
Sony Fox Marvel uh Marvel TV uh every
Marvel Universe we've ever had being an
element that all have to combine forces
even though some of that will mean
sacrifice for them and some of those
universes will die in order to take out
uh this entity doom and that'll all take
place on Battle world a world that Doom
basically runs and with the events of
that we get a prime timeline universally
and that eliminates uh messes of
continuity allowing for Figi and Co to
handpick characters and at the end of
that introducing X-Men and Fantastic
Four going forward what the
hell that a great that was a great call
okay okay oh we're almost done
guys jel power all right here we go we
got a couple from you my friend thank
you for it keep one of the other goes
granded stories like Joker Logan
Daredevil the Batman or big crazy teams
like Civil War ending game no way home
Guardians of the Galaxy uh grounded
stories man you've listed better movies
yeah uh the round I mean Logan is my I
love I think Logan
is probably my one of my top five
favorites of of the comic book ones I
mean I think that t like Logan no no I
do I do I just think te- ups are a
different animal it's like it's like do
you want pizza or do you want a salad do
you want a burger do you want a you know
what I mean hot always a pizza I
shouldn't put pizza with salad pizza or
Burger like it depends on your mood so I
don't think it's fair to I prefer
smaller grounded things but I wouldn't
want my no way home small and grounded
it had small and grounded intimate
moments but you still need the spectacle
of a reason why you'd have the three
Spider-Man so so I I feel like uh
they're different animals but I
generally prefer the grounded overall
because I prefer street level characters
to Cosmic but I think every story merits
a different tone so uh like D I like
Deadpool one two letter grades more than
Deadpool 2 uh Deadpool one is like an a
bordering on a plus for me whereas dead
is like a me
too
wait she being serious is she
with me I don't know but this is a funny
way to find out a crazy way to find
out
either she's trolling you at an 11 this
would be an insane way to find out or
she realizes that this would be the
reaction I be like there's a window I
could leave out through here I love that
no matter which direction it is I'm so
proud of
Olivia all I have is love for this
Choice okay there's a window here I
could hop out this way it's trolling
shut the channel down if I could just
get the camera bring it then be like
then you can record reactions of you on
the Run yeah this is
yeah Olivia genius no matter what genius
woman get in here congratulations greig
it's caught up to the CH we get in here
woman so good is this real I'm so happy
cuz this would be a insane way
to find out it's also an insane way to
out of this up thing in the world
honestly do oh it's so good
I've live I'm only live streaming to get
out of helping my wife this is so
funny I'm I can't I got nothing sorry
look if we have a baby coming our way I
got to honor the super chats oh this is
the best that's going to help take care
of the baby this is so good that $500
super chat's going a lot farther with
thought Netflix is d i Co rounding you
down to two
hours turn up it's my baby shower
gift what baby names you got it but
catch as overall MC and DC season 3 for
me with speak and I don't believe the
MCU will Top it well I agree man it's
going to be hard for them to top
Daredevil I'm focusing on your super
chats yeah we're gonna get through them
I agree season 3 is is pretty PE but I
think season one is a little bit my more
mod jam and season two is my favorite of
them so it's 213 and uh it is hard to
top Dar I thought she had her whatever
Mike Sanchez I do you think season two
of Loki is
better than that makes season one work
is that it sticks The Landing like are
you this is so can you just come in here
funny to me this is amazing this I
already thought Olivia was great now
she's transcending she's like she's at
another level do you think season two of
Loki is better than one uh I think I
think season one is better and if this
sticks The Landing like one did it might
be but episode two and a few other
little foilables don't quite stick for
me I think the directing might be better
because there's some great directing but
Jacob hin thanks for the Super Chat just
overwhelmed right now this is are you
joking
she's choking Jesus
Christ I don't even smoke a smoker cough
I was oh man she just opened the door
and rubbed her belly you you know her if
you know her if you you know we can go
either really could have been
the funniest go it could go like she
could actually be cuz you know she could
she would screenshot it and have you
know that if she did that she would
record this as having proof of your
reaction she would keep that for ever
that you kept on this stream with her
pregnant without you would know a th%
like is she could be choking or she
literally opened the door and rubbed her
belly before deciding to tell him it
wasn't true oh god oh that was so those
five minutes will live on in my heart
forever Jacob henen that was amazing oh
my
God congratulations you're not the
father I mean I would have I would have
done I would have been I would have been
like all right let's do it man Little
John cute yes we call him John Coy ala
get over here John Coy Roxy ala John Coy
we're not going to call Rock John John
Coy Alba get over here oh man full name
when you're mad at him all right that
was so good ol jaob hey guys big fan
love Loki so far I got an off top
question about Ben Ry do you think Sony
should make a live action movie about
him nah I don't think it'll work uh Ben
riy to me is like an existential crisis
as a character I don't think that Tom uh
wants to play the character that dark
yet I think we need a lot more Tom
Holland in Solo stories uh and more
contained like small town stuff but I
would love one day to see a clone soag I
just don't think that Now's the
Time first thing I'm going to teach my
baby this is how you do Chinese yep it's
going to grow up in a very welc world
how you be a black guy welcoming world
is coming to that baby he is Gonna Be
Love now I'm Latino man I'm just are you
from oh
it's gonna be a great baby man it's
gonna be a great baby like it's an item
you can drink to be great baby it's a
COI that's hilarious that's so funny
it's a CO Olen oent oh man is this our
final one hello well hello there I think
it's our final one yeah
um if Majors now the chat's
disappointed I wanted you to
just suddenly be dealt a brand new
responsibility I was ready for 18 years
of stress on this
No Sleep life that you currently have
you're already so
rested s and we're GRE doesn't have
enough responsibility why if it happens
I would totally I declar right now I'm I
would GL I will do it I've told her that
to him like Hey if you happen to get
pregnant we're doing it yeah
great dad I totally see you popping up
but man I'm was like but we need to be
doing it more and then she's like never
mind and I'm like that's understandable
and now it's got to be even longer if
Majors doesn't stay in the king roll Co
I'm sorry you're going to buy me 20
minutes thank you my friend you're a
really kind guy if he just doesn't stay
in the Kang roll do you prefer to scrap
the plan start for the character and go
in another direction or recast and say
the course um what do you think co uh I
think you focus I know fair you just
through a pregnancy uh I I would go with
a uh a recast personally I think that
Jonathan major is an incredible actor I
think one of the strengths of the
character is that you can play it so
multifaceted you'd have to have an
incredible actor but I think they've set
up too much uh around the character to
just scrap it like there's no way to
just go nope didn't happen at this point
in the game but the actor would have to
be as incredible as Jonathan major which
is no tall uh which is quite the tall
order yeah man because that's the point
of the character is that it's one actor
playing just get Don Cheeto man she's
ready as both characters multivers all
right we'll round you up to three and a
half that was so funny like that was
just gold all right Coy we got one last
we got one more all right
um let's see here is it two
more that's quick round up let's get it
quick round up here next time baby next
time baby that's funny that's so
funny that's so funny so funny
oh man gamer MJ did you play
Spider-Man 2 yet he has not personally
this game of the year for me and
complete and got all the trophies in
three days God damn wow gamer completely
I get what you did on the channel stream
l l take to your own personal dashboard
have to Google it oh that's
sucks uh also gamer MJ you live up to
your name excellent work that's incred I
appreciate you for understanding
especially for being a gamer thank you
do you think Gareth Edward should direct
a Marvel movie Gareth Edwards is the
creator one okay if so what one he
absolutely killed it with the Creator as
stated here also would Insomniac
Spider-Man be on Miguel's side and at
the cross the spiderverse Spider-Man is
my all-time favorite character and no
way home you sp all alltime fav till
across the
spiderverse beautiful I uh I Lov to
cross spiderverse as well no way home is
still I I keep live action like MCU I
don't put Sony's Universe into the MCU
yet because it's not quite yet but
getting there that said uh those are two
of my five star films uh I would say
Gareth Edwards with his resume would do
really well with a big scope craziness
so I would say something of scale I
think he'd make an interesting Thor
because they're looking for a Thor
director I think Thor five with like
something biblical in scope like
something that's just enormous fighting
Thor like you actually get something
that feels like um back to the hell
scale you know something like huge like
maybe Baler comes back maybe it's it's I
would love to be honest what I would
love Thor five to be is him accepting
that Ragnarok isn't complete because in
mythology Ragnarok isn't over until Thor
is dead and Thor sacrificing himself for
a universe reboot and that ties into
Secret Wars I think it'd be really
interesting if Thor 5 ties into Secret
Wars and the universe including aurons
can't reset because there's so much um
uh afterlife stuff tied into the the
universe right now we've got the M
Marvel afterlife we've got the field of
reads we've got all the stuff with the
Egyptians we've got so many after lives
it'd be cool if Thor dying was was
allowing the Ragnarok to take place in
all the universes resetting tying into
secret War so I'd make a big biblical uh
Creator esque uh Thor five wow if they
got Terence Howard for
King who would not who who would not be
curious to see that so funny why would
you not be curious and then you could
like have some weird tie in of how he
like affected first EP hilarious yeah uh
also
I I would cast yaa personally all right
guys let's see how many people we
actually after three and a half hours or
close to how many people do we end with
here 690 still wow that's crazy damn
that's that's amazing that's incredible
thank you guys that's really really
sweet of you guys thank you that means a
lot 700 people still in after three and
a half hours of absurdity that's
wild dude that's truly special thank you
and concurrence are strong all righty
guys well we're going to end this stream
now I got to go help out my not pregnant
life um that's that was the best like Co
and I have different workout routines
you know like he can touch his toes and
kick like a so I don't I
don't think I can compare yeah man like
you you're you're mainly you're mainly
focused on weightlifting yeah like I'm a
bodybuild kind of guy because it's it's
how I get my anger out I only weightlift
three times a week I've been doing
martial arts punches Bing back into that
but I do waited to get some tone typing
in the triceps yeah yeah his triceps
crazy I do 5 days weights where Greg
just I have like a tone bicep but you
got like bulk you got Mass on you yeah I
build build and I do cardio like once a
week whereas Greg's always like changing
his routine two to three times I like I
do cardio at the gym once a week I walk
with a weighted vest to get some
resistance in Nice Like long or time
okay got it got it and uh the other day
I went on a run for the first time a
long time but I think because I've been
doing like weighted vest walking I'm
able to run better it totally builds
cardiovascular yeah and my knees I was
like oh I'm running faster even though I
haven't ran in months but I'm Piccolo
technique take off the big weighted and
I ran with I ran like almost three miles
without music cuz my headphones wer work
you know I was like I've never been able
to do this I don't have that in
I was like I don't know I pulled
I was very stressed that day what was H
there was something that happened that
day that stressed me out so much yeah I
was so stressed that I was like it
I'm going on a run and uh I haven't ran
in a bit and I need to uh my cardio's
been like in the house so I need I need
to get better I wish this were true
otherwise i' I'd be
we Le that's true that's true here we
are man that was that was a good stream
that was a favorite stream uh that was a
really fun time guys thank you so much
for being here I just messed up the
dimensions I bet of of this of
everything but let's get a couple of
final I can't just like bring this back
to what it was love artha hello hello uh
g kby p Kevin Hart is Kang is hilarious
to me uh the doomers had a fun time
Adrian King agreed he would be a great
dad Papa Greg doing the work just we we
don't have to worry about the next like
you know nine months from today at this
point maybe nine months from tomorrow I
am truthfully scared as to be a dad
but I want to be a dad so bad who I am
now the person I am now I feel like I've
become in the last couple years I feel
like if the time comes for it I would
gladly rise to the occasion and I feel
like I do a good job I just know me well
enough to know like I'm putting my all
this and everything I do that child's
going to mirror me in every way
so I got to be really aware I
have to be good so they can be good on
me they're going to everything they're
going to learn from me I got to be more
influential than when they're going to
school yeah going to be so aware of
every bit of psychology worth it I think
be great but yeah guys round of goodbyes
here before we head out round of quick
goodbyes oh my God thatv Maria Chase G
or Christian unpronouncable Big D Big D
Dan v900 thank you to everyone who
contributed to our super chats it goes a
long way thank you to Coy of course for
being here uh next time probably be Co
and John thank you to uh everyone who
contributed to our streamlab and if you
didn't contribute that's a just
appreciate you chiming in on the live
stream I really do I really do love
doing live streams I gladly live stream
for hours versus editing for hours even
though there's one I do every day for
hours that's why this is preferable but
thank you guys so much um and really
like if you ever see us in person please
come say hi and if we do a live event in
person we'll be sure to let you know
might recorded might live stream it
probably live we haven't recorded
putting them up which people don't know
how great and weird they are yeah
they're very
great yeah they're very different and
they're very interactive and I think
people would really really enjoy them
and it's an actual dialogue which I love
cuz I know what it's like to be in the
audience and kind of wish what I was
watching and and then I I like to kind
of bring that I really hope and and I
think we're all so loose and don't give
a yeah we literally bring out like
mics to the a like it's crazy ComiCon
John went outside and chased someone
outside no way he's like come watch our
P so funny yeah it was great let's let's
do more it was really funny uh
Jud Miller thanks for that last minute
sticker all righty guys thank you so
much for everything much love Greg you
fat what a terrible way to end this
stream I was just I shouted him out also
Greg's not I promise I've gained more
weight in the last two weeks than Greg
or two months thatone that's true that's
look at that that's insane dude so much
better vascularity and tone that's
bananas you've actually got that t going
down getting my forearms because of you
that helps I got before I didn't have
forearms yeah but you get those little
break heels man break heel makes the
whole arm look better yeah like I see it
here I haven't had that until like the
last month no way so it really did help
that much that's red yeah you like it
right there Flex that there I never used
to have this now yeah that's literally
from like the hammer curls and stuff
yeah now I'm like oh I need to kind of
do this then adjust that
but now and now like when you do your
biceps look bigger because your triceps
are bigger but then that rounds your
arms out so you don't look weird in
t-shirts doing these now little forearm
curls any you doing the tri our street
flexing oh thank you Stephanie Horton
for everything oh thank you for a last
one um appreciate you guys thank you
Stephanie that's really and I know
you're also one of our patrons thank you
all righty guys see okay I'm going I'm
leaving she's actually there you
shouldn't have said you shouldn't have
said you weren't pregnant
[Music]
otherwise I did
know SP